[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
number four somewhere
[Applause]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good good morning how are you
good morning how are you
all right
circuit court of fairfax county is now
in second year
please be serious all right good morning
all right if i could have council
approach for a moment please
all right are we ready for the journey
i put my microphone on sorry judy
are you ready for the jury okay thank
you
yes
oh
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen
all right dr hughes if you come back to
the stand for me please
all right thank you good morning good
morning all right cross examination
thank you
good morning dr hughes i'm wayne dennis
and we haven't met before no good
morning good morning
you testified yesterday that you have to
give
a careful attention
to gendered stereotypes
that is correct
uh when you're talking about in intimate
partner violence you have to pay
attention to gendered stereotypes
and during your testimony you in fact
paid attention
to gendered stereotypes correct
i'm not sure what you mean well
you said we were going to have to pay
attention to gendered stereotypes
and then you testified at length
where you reference both men and women
you paid attention to those stereotypes
during the course of your testimony
correct
what i was saying was you have to pay
attention to gendered stereotypes when
you're conducting these evaluations you
can't assume all the time that the male
is the perpetrator and the female is the
victim you have to go into the
evaluation understanding that the male
also could be the victim of intimate
partner violence in fact you're aware
that there are large-scale studies
that do say that ipv towards males does
exist of course
okay
and every time
you refer to the characteristic of a
victim
of intimate partner violence yesterday
you used the pronouns she or her didn't
you
i was using the she and her pronouns in
this case because my determination was
as i stated that miss heard was the
victim of intimate partner violence that
is why i was using the she her pronouns
you infected women gets into the
relationship for all the right reasons
that's what you said woman gets into the
relationship for all the right reasons
and then you say difficult
for her for victim to extricate
herself
you go on to say that she can and she
should
over and over you use sheep right
i believe in this case i did because i
was referencing this case where i found
misheard to be the victim of intimate
partner violence it doesn't mean that
men don't get into the relationships for
all the right reasons too i believe they
do
nearly every time you referenced
the perpetrator of ipv
you use hear him didn't you
and it goes back to the same reasoning
as i'm describing my understanding and
my evaluation in this matter of course
men can be perpetrators and victims of
intimate partner violence that's well
established in the research and that's
well established in my clinical practice
as well isn't the reason that you've
used
the pronouns that you did
that you almost always testify on behalf
of a woman
that's not correct you don't even
remember the last time you testified on
behalf of a man
well i don't
testify on behalf of someone i testify
as to the results of my evaluation i
frequently treat and assess male victims
of childhood sexual abuse who are coming
into treatment for
abuse by their boy scout leader by their
cat with a coach by their teacher by a
trusted adult i see them in therapy i
see them in forensic matters in criminal
cases so i treat and evaluate men all
the time i didn't ask you about
treatment i asked you about testimony
you talked you broke out your practice
between treatment and testimony i'm not
asking about treatment
when's the last time you testified on
behalf of a man
i testified recently in a deposition on
behalf of a man who was traumatized
because he was wrongly convicted
at the time of your deposition
six weeks ago you couldn't remember a
single time you testified on behalf of a
man i testified in my deposition that i
testified in a case of a man who was
wrongly convicted about 20 years and
suffered physical and sexual violence in
prison and i detailed the traumatic
effects of the that that happened on
that gentleman all right why don't we
take a look at your deposition sure
all right thank you
yes
thank you
all right
transcript of the deposition that you
gave
march 28 2022 correct yes
all right
let's go to
page 77.
let's look at
let's
page 70 land eight
so you can't recall a single instance
where you were hired by the attorney
representing the mail
in an ipv matter correct
in an ipv matter not in a trauma matter
or a child sexual abuse matter okay so
that's the distinction you've nev you
don't have any recollection of ever
testifying on behalf of a male in an ipv
matter as i stated yesterday the very
first case that i testified in wasn't a
same-sex intimate partner violence where
the man was the victim of another man i
routinely treat and assess same-sex
couples where then the female can be the
perpetrator of another female and the
male can be the perpetrator or a victim
of his partner
so
let me get this you testified in a case
where one male
is alleged to have engaged in a ipv
against another male
correct
okay
but that's the only one you're around
that's the only one you remember you
remember
no i've done this frequently as you well
know most cases don't go to trial i've
worked on hundreds and hundreds of cases
you've limited to testimony many cases
don't come to trial but i've issued
reports and worked on many cases of
same-sex intimate partner violence where
men are the victims but but i did ask
you about testimony and
and i limited your the question to
testimony
and the only testimony that you remember
is the two is the same-sex couple right
there were multiple same-sex couples i
believe that i tested they testified in
court at trial i believe so yes all
right but you didn't remember that in
in march i did remember that in march
okay
uh you're a professional witness correct
that's not correct no you make
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
testifying in court correct
not testifying in court i conduct
thorough comprehensive psychological
evaluations of individuals who are
involved in a court case the majority of
those cases never show up in a courtroom
and half of my practice and half of my
income is about my clinical work with
people who are coming to me for therapy
i didn't ask you about the other half of
your income i'm asking you whether you
made a hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year
testifying as an expert witness in court
as you're phrasing that question that's
not correct i that would be the amount
of income that i generate from my
forensic practice i testify perhaps
maybe once or twice a year the best of
most of the work is done behind the
scenes in evaluating individuals and
issuing reports but you'll agree with me
that
a big part of that practice is providing
expert witness testimony that's not
correct
no
that's not a big part of your practice
if i testify twice a year that's not a
big part of my practice all the other
time is doing the work for the cases and
evaluating the individuals and issuing
reports
all right what percentage
of work do you
devote to forensic psychology
as i stated yesterday i i say half and
half clinical half forensic but i also
have a substantial amount of time that i
use in the professional activities and
serving on professional boards
so
what portion of your practice do you
provide
expert witness services
i think you're using the expert witness
services synonymous with the forensic
psychology part of the practice so the
forensic psychology practice what i do
here today is one part of it and it's a
smaller part as opposed to all of the
evaluations and individuals that i'm
assessing
your
practice is successful enough that you
maintain your offices on madison avenue
in new york correctly
correct i've had that office since 2005.
right
um and you're sufficiently successful at
your uh forensic work
that you're able to perform unpaid work
at a hospital correct
correct and i also do pro bono work as
well
in fact you actually instruct others on
the use of expert testimony in court
cases correct
on the use and understanding trauma and
violence abuse in the courtroom and how
to for advocates and people who could
not have
this level of training or experience how
to come into the courtroom and talk
about very difficult issues of domestic
violence yes
can we pull up px1241
do you recognize that document
uh yes it looks like the front page of a
powerpoint presentation
and it's a powerpoint presentation given
by home by myself and marianne dutton
who is a
very well-known and respected researcher
and clinician in the area of domestic
violence
and what's the topic of the powerpoint
that you're giving expert witness
testimony in cases involving domestic
violence
okay
and who did you give this uh
presentation to
that was to the national clearinghouse
for the defense of battered women um
that is an organization that provides
legal services to
women who have assaulted or killed their
partners in self-defense and mostly
people who these individuals
the woman who they've seen in treatment
are through shelter-based programs or
through advocates and those are
individuals who don't really know how to
come into the courtroom and talk and
that's what what this um presentation
and training was for
i'm going to move uh px 1241 into
evidence
any objection
all right 12 41 in evidence you can do
you want it published or yes let's
publish it to the jerk thank you
all right
why don't we pull up px1242
do you recognize this document yes this
also looks like a powerpoint
presentation that i gave
all right what is the name of this
powerpoint presentation
this is called the use of psychological
experts in cases of domestic violence it
was presented to the kings county bar
association which is in brooklyn
and what this presentation talked about
was some of the things that i talked to
you all about yesterday the myths and
misconceptions in intimate partner
violence when women use force what
happens if they drop protective orders
how they present in court and that's
what this presentation was to attorneys
at the bar association
okay but this is another presentation
that you gave
uh
as to the use of psychological experts
and you gave it to a to a bar
association right they were prosecutors
and defense attorneys in attendance at
that bar association
your deposition you
testified that you were going to be paid
100 an hour for your time in this case
i did not testify to that you did not
that's an error in the transcript oh
that's not that's not right that's
correct so and you corrected the
transcript we did not do an errata in
the transcript at this point so you knew
there was an error in the transcript but
you didn't fix it there were several
errors in the transcript but didn't fix
any
there was no time to fix them that's
correct all right so you're not being
paid a hundred dollars an hour how much
are you getting paid i'm being paid 500
an hour 500 an hour and that's what um
and that's the bill you set for your
deposition right 500 an hour correct
uh
you submitted a number of
disclosures in this case
you have not formed an opinion
as to whether mr depp committed internet
intimate partner violence against
misheard
correct
correct i formed the opinion that miss
heard's report of the intimate partner
violence is consistent with what we know
in the literature about intimate partner
violence
you have
a limited role here
comparing individual data to group data
and then just determining whether it's
consistent right
i wouldn't say it's a limited role but
that's generally correct
you wouldn't use the word limited role a
limited role in terms of how we go about
a forensic evaluation not a limited role
in this case do you remember whether you
use limited role in your deposition
i don't if you have it in front of me
you probably think i did but sure
uh
and you have no independent knowledge of
the facts underlying the alleged abuse
correct
i have the knowledge of the plethora of
documents that i've reviewed in this
case i'm asking you your independent
first-hand knowledge you have none of
that right
you mean whether i was there yeah you
weren't there of course not okay
um and you're not testifying to the
veracity the truthfulness
of any of the allegations
correct i'm testifying to the
consistency of the data points of all
the different documents including the
psychological testing and the clinical
evaluation that i conducted of misheard
and how that comports with the therapy
records and all the other documents and
the photos and texts that i reviewed
and you have no personal knowledge of
any abuse
correct personally correct right
and all you know is what misheard
self-reported to you and others
that's not correct
because you did collateral interviews
and i reviewed medical records and i
reviewed other witness statements of
what they witnessed and what they saw
and all of those
statements that you reviewed
those are statements that started with
misheard correct
not necessarily well the medical records
did didn't they
well the medical records if she's
self-reporting what happened to her sure
i mean that's what we do when we go to a
physician we say i have a headache we're
self-reporting our difficulties
everything misheard reported directly to
you
was after she was sued by mr depp in
this case correct
and you didn't
meet miss heard until what september
2019 that was the first evaluation
appointment correct
how'd you get engaged
engaged
how did you get hired to do this work
um i was contacted by the legal team
were you interviewed by her legal team
as to whether you were going to testify
here i was not you were not interviewed
i was not you were contacted correct had
you worked with that legal team before i
had yeah so they already knew who you
were right
correct right
and at any time that you were working
with miss heard or assessing miss heard
she could have chose to fire you correct
i suppose her legal team could have
chose to fire i was not her she is not
my client the legal team is the one who
hires me i am responsible to the legal
team not misheard and this legal and the
legal team that hired you already knew
who you were because you worked together
previously
and clearly they knew of my expertise in
this area of intimate partner violence
and traumatic stress which is why
they contacted me to work on this matter
all right several times yesterday you
used language about
assessing ms heard's relationship
with mr depp do you remember talking
about that sure
you can't assess a relationship
without talking to both parties can you
you certainly can get a lot of
information from one party absolutely
and especially when it's buttressed by
other documents including four years of
therapy records and couples therapy
records you can get a lot of information
based on those documents and that
contemporaneous reports of the
relationship
respectively i didn't ask whether you
get a lot of information i asked whether
you can assess a relationship without
talking to both parties
i believe you can there are certainly
limitations inherent in that but you
certainly can
[Music]
you talked to miss herd for what
approximately 30 hours right correct
how long you spent with mr depp i did
not spend any time with mr depp it was
my understanding that he did not sit for
a psychological evaluation right in fact
you never met mr depp i have not but you
purport to be able to assess the
relationship between mr depp and miss
heard
but i also read mr depp's transcripts of
his testimony i watched his deposition
testimony i reviewed his medical records
i reviewed his text messages so it's not
necessarily totally blind i did have
information although i'm not making a
conclusion about mr depp himself is the
standard now not necessarily totally
blind
that's how you assess the relationship
if it's not necessarily totally blind i
can assess it
we recess as clinical psychologists
relationships all the time that's what
we're trained to do certainly someone
who's been trained in intimate partner
violence to understand and look for the
dynamics that happen in that
relationship and then when we have
external data that supports what the
individual is telling us way before this
legal case even came on the scene that
becomes very strong data to support that
conclusion let's talk about some of that
data sure all right
uh you chose to conduct some collateral
interviews correct right
um and you interviewed dr bonnie jacobs
correct
and you looked at her notes
correct
and you know
that
miss jacobs
dr jacobs
uh
doesn't know anything about
the version of what happened in
australia until miss heard had already
been sued correct
i believe she was not in treatment with
dr jacobs at the time the australia
incident occurred so that would be
correct she did reach out to dr connell
cohen about australia who she was
treating with at that time
contemporaneously all right i'll ask you
about dr cohen we'll get there
so
uh
you know that miss heard stop seeing dr
jacobs in august 2014. that's correct
she didn't go back until after she got
sued right
i believe that's the date i'd have to
look to make sure but i believe that
you're correct
and you said you reviewed
you interviewed dr connell cohen that's
correct
and you also reviewed his deposition
testimony that's correct
and you know that when
that he testified that when he was
treating a patient he assumes the
patient is telling the truth correct
i believe he said something to that
effect in his deposition
if he has no reason to believe otherwise
if there's no other data to believe
otherwise that your patient's not being
totally honest with you then you believe
what they're saying right no other data
to believe otherwise but the sole thing
that's happening is miss heard is
talking to mr cohen
or dr cohen
i wouldn't say she's talking to him
she's going to him for therapy and he's
using his clinical psychological
expertise to understand the connection
between her symptoms and what she's
reporting what's going on in her life
but you understand that he testified
that he assumes the patient is telling
the truth
again i understand that statement in his
testimony i have a lot more rich
information of having spoken to him for
two hours and reviewing his clinical
notes
he testified he was making a leap of
faith with respect to that right with
respect to the truthfulness
again that was not my understanding of
speaking with him and reviewing his
notes i'm aware he testified something
to that effect
and you testified yesterday that dr
cohen never diagnosed ms hurd with any
personality disorders you remember that
yes in fact
dr cohen's deposition testimony reflects
the fact that he doesn't make diagnosis
correct
correct and i asked him specifically did
he have any indications that even if he
doesn't as his practice use them
does she be criteria for a personality
disorder and he told me she did not all
right so you asked him specifically with
respect to a topic that you haven't
disclosed in your
expert report
and then
he made a conclusion that's reflected in
no
document it's reflected in my notes it's
reflected in his notes about what he's
treating he's treating the symptoms he's
not focusing on the diagnosis but he is
treating the symptoms
you talked about dr cohen's concern for
ms hurt's safety
correct
he wasn't talking about her physical
safety was he yes he was no he was
talking about her emotional safety
wasn't that what he was talking about he
was concerned for both okay
did dr cohen testify that he never had
the feeling that johnny intended to hurt
miss hurd
i believe he said that i mean he talked
about mr depp being very poorly
controlled and that's what made him him
dr cohen concerned because in those
moments when he was not controlled that
he could accidentally seriously hurt
miser
let's do this again
miss heard told dr cohen that mr debt
was poorly controlled correct that's not
correct okay
he determined that from
the in the treatment he was providing
misheard
and he also had a couple session with mr
depp and he also had correspondence with
dr kipper
so he had other information as to mr
depp's functioning
all right you talked about dr banks
correct
dr banks was doing relationship
consulting right consultation in a
relationship correct
and dr banks only met with them once
correct
and you did
an interview i think with uh
ms hurt's mother page that's correct all
right
you'd agree with me that a person's
family member is not the most objective
source of information
sometimes you have to certainly control
for that that the person may be
wanting to be protective of um of their
daughter of course
and you interviewed miss
paige hurd
after mr deputy arguments had already
sued uh amber
right the entirety of my work in this
case happened obviously after the
lawsuit did you review in that context
any of uh paige heard's text messages
with with mr den
i'm not sure if i saw them with mr depp
i do believe i saw some with miss heard
i mean miss heard miss paige heard paige
heard amber heard's mother did talk to
me about her relationship with mr demp
and she told you that she loved johnny
even after
amber alleged abuse correct she did all
right
now you testified that you approach a
forensic evaluation with i think you
said it again today
a healthy degree
of skepticism
correct
all right
this skepticism
didn't
cause you to conduct
interviews
with
for instance
laurel anderson
right i did not speak to dr laurel
anderson
and you chose not to speak to dr laurel
anderson
because you disagreed with dr laurel
anderson
that's not correct all right you know
what did dr laurel anderson do on behalf
of
ms heard and mr depp
she was a couples therapist that they
sought they had four couples sessions
as i stated yesterday one of them in
which mr depp uh stormed out of she did
have a
long
i guess evaluation or interview with mr
depp individually and with miss heard
individually and then she saw them
um intersp intermittently after um
the may 21st 2016 incident and they when
they were filing for divorce
so you didn't interview uh laurel
anderson
but you know what she did how'd you
figure that out
because we had her redacted notes and
her deposition
all right
and you
understood from her deposition
that dr anderson didn't believe miss
heard to be a victim of spousal abuse i
believe those were her words yes
and you also understood from her
deposition
that mr depp had not had a very long
history of being violent with any of his
wife or women
that she said that as well yeah
but that something about misheard
significantly triggered him she talked
about that as well
and dr anderson thought that
mr depp had been uh
her words well controlled
i think for almost 20 or 30 years
correct
up until this point i believe she said
um
i know that you testified that you
reviewed medical records
yes
all right
so
you know misheard had a personal nurse
correct
uh aaron flotti
correct
you didn't interview miss felotti either
i did not uh
you know she spent time with miss heard
on a regular basis during her
relationship with mr depp
correct i had her clinical notes that i
reviewed right
and you reviewed her test or deposition
testimony correct some of which the
jury's heard right i believe so yeah
uh and you've
reviewed the nursing notes
yes
so you know
that ms heard admitted to it history of
eating disorders to miss pilate correct
i know that's in the notes that's
nowhere else in any other record so i'm
not sure where that came from but you
relied on everybody else's notes
and there are some things that i
disagreed with like i disagree with dr
laurel anderson about it being mutual
abuse right so the stuff you disagree
with you disregard and the rest you keep
correct
that's not correct
but that's what you did that's not
correct
um you know that
ms
flotti
some has heard immediately after she
returned from australia
i'd have to look at the notes again to
be sure but i know she did see her when
she came back from australia that's
correct
did ms valadi
document any injuries to misheard
in her notes
i did not see that in the record okay so
you looked at her notes and there's no
injury to misheard documented in her
nurse's notes
following her return from australia
correct okay
you talked about
uh this concept
uh which is then defined uh lethality
and you testified there are certain
factors their present relationship where
a woman ends up
murdered by her partner
correct
and that's one of the ways you look as
to whether a woman is in a very
dangerous situation correct
can we put px92
public to the journal it will be
published
do you know what this is
i believe this is the um
knife that misheard gave to mr depp as a
gift
all right
and you speak spanish
do you know what it says yes it says
until death
so a woman you
suggest
has characteristics of being afraid for
her life
gives her intimate partner a large knife
which she is inscribed until death
that's your testimony
well there's context
okay
we can do that later
so we talked about
you talked a little about about
uh
mr depp
purporting to
demonstrate uh jealousy with miss heard
do you recall that yes i do
uh
and you specifically talked about
mr displaying jealousy regarding uh
the actor james franco correct
now
the very first time
you met
with ms heard
she talked to you about miss franco mr
frank of james frank correct
i don't know if it was the first time
but i did ask about some other
relationships okay
so
why don't we do this
let's go uh
px1246
i just want to go the first page
all right
so
do you recognize the document that's in
front of you yes
all right
and
what i would like to do what is it
um it's one uh a top sheet of a
background information questionnaire
that i use to help guide the evaluation
okay
so
now
this is who filled it out i filled it
out whose form is it my form all right
i'm going to move
just the first page into evidence
because we're going to talk about other
portions of it later could you back us
as soon as you see the whole first page
any objection
okay
we will admit the whole thing into
evidence you want the whole thing in
evidence sure no objection whatsoever
all right 12 46 in evidence in full
okay
are there any are there any identifiers
that need are we just we're just going
yeah i'm sure there's going to be some
all right probably
okay so you owe me a redacted one
correct
don't know what the nature of the
redactions are going to be but okay well
you can discuss we'll work with okay
thank you all
um
1246
uh has been moved into evidence can we
blow up the bottom right hand corner all
right you want to publish to the jury
yeah let's publish it to the jury
i don't
have to do it
or we can it won't want you um
i don't see anything on the first page
you want to look at that
any objection to that
well that's what they're going to show
that's what we're going to show
okay all right publish soon
all right
all right so this is the bottom
bottom corner
your notes
um and it's under the section of your
notes that's entitled intimate
relationships correct right
and
one of the notes here on the right it
says
jf
that's james james franco right correct
got close but really wanted to to be
with johnny
well it says you have friends they were
friends all right
said friends but you put him under
intimate relationship well there's a
line there because i was asking
specifically about other things that
were allegations in this matter
there's a line there because
you did not believe
that they should go under intimate
relationships but it's on your form
she wasn't telling me that this was an
intimate relationship i queried as to
what's going on with james franco
because that was something that was
raised in this case
and there's a note for december 2050
when they became more friends more
friendly right and that was a period of
time in which
ms heard was married to mr dutt correct
correct
so she became close with mr franco
in december 2015
and
at least you put it under intimate
relationships
with a line differentiating another part
of this document okay
did you provide another header like the
header that says friends
no no well let's look at the next one
the next one says i think it says elon
correct it's elon musk right correct all
right
may 2016.
correct
met ball correct that's a big fancy
party in new york right yes it is
and she said she dated him after johnny
correct
she met elon musk
in may
when
2016.
you file the tro
uh the last sentence it was may 21st i
believe it was may 26 27th
i'm correct when did she start dating
elon musk
sometime after that
sometime after the tro
i believe so yes okay
you talk we can take that down
you talked uh quite a lot yesterday
about this concept of uh reactive
violence
yes yeah um
so i just so i understand your position
on this
is it your position that
if miss heard was abused
she gets to hit mr death
that's not my opinion
but you know she hits him right
and i testified to that right and how
many times do you believe that she told
you that she hit him
do i believe that she told me or how
many instances were there well i don't
know how you how would you know other
than her telling you you weren't there
right i was not there that's correct
all right
how many times did she admit to eddie
she indicated a number of times in a
number of instances
um
you indicated
that you would listen to audio
recordings as part of the work you did
in this case that's correct
all right i'd like to play a portion of
one of those recordings
it's plain exhibit 343.
it's already in evidence
and for the record the portion i want to
play is
two minutes 46
uh
to 247
0.20
i said to travis i said no i said to you
hey
tell travis what just happened oh you're
telling me to do it you told me to you
said go do that i said no tell him what
you're saying all right why and that you
punched me in the [ __ ]
by the way you i'm sorry that i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched
don't tell me what it feels like to be
punished you know you've been a lot of
fights been around a long time and i
know yeah when you [ __ ] have a
closure you didn't get punched you got
hit i'm sorry i hit you like this but i
did not punch you i did not [ __ ] deck
you i [ __ ] was hitting you i don't
know what the boat motion of my actual
hand was but you're fine i did not hurt
you i did not punch you i was hitting
you how are you how what am i supposed
to do do this
i'm not sitting here bitching about it
am i you are that's the difference
between me and you you're a [ __ ] baby
you are such a baby girl the [ __ ] up
johnny physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
because
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable
you agree with miss heard that it's
admirable to retreat from a fight
is it is it admirable to it is admirable
to retreat from a fight yeah
um
anything about this tape suggest to you
that it's characteristic of reactive
violence
in this instance if true if she said she
hit him first then that would not be
reactive violence
all right you testified that
miss herd reported to you that she
engaged in low levels of violence
correct
well i don't think she said that i think
that was the characterization of knowing
the types of minor and severe levels of
violence okay
i got it wrong
you consider low levels of violence well
i consider what the literature and the
research talks about low levels of
violence as opposed to severe um levels
of violence and i think
you suggested if you that uh miss hurt
sustained more severe
uh
injuries correct i think i said more
frequent injuries more frequent but not
more severe
well certainly
the incidents in australia and the
sexual violence and the incidents on
december 15 2015 were quite severe
um
you said you reviewed medical records in
rendering your opinion
correct
and you
you reviewed photographs
correct now other than the
reports
to her therapists
which you call medical records right
yeah i would call those medical records
sure other than the reports to her
therapist there's not a single medical
record that reflects any injury to
misheard is there that's not correct
there is not a other than
what doctor reflected injuries to
misheard
the note by aaron borham her married
name philadelphia her married name
indicated that she was head butted by mr
depp and that she went for a concussion
check and she had a busted lip and then
she went to dr kipper's office in order
to get checked
what and there's a medical record other
than that note that reflects it
there's a note that she showed up at dr
kipper's office there's a note in the
center of two days that doctor laurel
anderson saw the two bruises from that
same incident as well all right um
you reviewed photographs yes
um
i'd like to put up px144
it's been published in the jury briefly
i'm going to keep it up very briefly
that photograph
doesn't reflect a low level of violence
well that reflects a severe injury i
would agree yeah why don't we go to px
145.
that's a severe injury that ended up
with mr depp
on a gurney correct
that is a severe injury correct
there
is it your testimony
that
throwing a can of mineral spirits
at your spouse's characteristic
of reactive violence
if you are running away from your spouse
who is trying to hurt you yes
all right so so you can throw a can of
mineral spirits
what about if you throw a can of red
bull
again it depends on what the incident i
think that you're referring to that was
not necessarily reactive violence that
was in a state of frustration or anger
right so
so when you throw a can of red bull in a
state of frustration or anger that's not
reactive violence
what about if you throw a bottle of
vodka because your husband fell off the
wagon
is that reactive
violence
are you asking me hypothetically i'm
asking you would that ki would that be a
characteristic
of
of reactive violence throw a bottle of
vodka because your husband fell off the
wagon
if it's in the middle of an assault
perhaps
if it's independent of that
no
right so for instance if your husband
was just having a couple of shots at the
bar
again you would need more information in
context make that determination all
right
you don't think that's a reflection
reflective
of reactive violence and you'll agree
with me
that when you throw the second bottle
that's not reactive violence
if somebody's throwing multiple bottles
again psychological violence and abuse
is psychologically destabilizing which
destabilizes individuals coping
strategies that is absolutely true
lost what's true
is it your testimony that
once you've thrown one bottle and missed
when you throw the second one
now it's reactive violence that's not
what i'm saying
i don't think throwing bottles is
acceptable in any context
all right i'm going to ask you about
some of the testing that you uh did
one of the
things that you
did
was a uh
was a form that looked like uh called a
cts2
relationship behaviors form
of the conflict tactics scale correct
so cts2 stands for conflict tactics
scale that's correct
and this is one of the documents that um
you had with you
on the on the stand yesterday i had all
my testing with me and all my clinical
notes from my evaluation with misurge
and you gave me
a copy of it because you looked at it
during the testimony because you asked
me so i gave it to you yes right all
right
but you have a good recollection what
that test is about the cts2 test i have
a very good memory and a very good
recollection i want to give the jury the
most
accurate and thorough information ever
having done 12 tests with so many
questions i wanted to just be as
accurate as possible i'm sure my memory
would miss some things that might be
relevant all right so let's talk about
the cts2
it's dated 926 2019
2019 correct all right 9 26
2019
and it goes through and it asks a whole
series of questions
about
what
you've done
and what your partner has done that's
correct
there's tons of these questions
correct
and every single one of those questions
is preceded by the same question right
how often did this happen
in the past year correct
you knew that as uh as of 9 26 2019
not a single one of the things
that ms
heard identified happened to her in the
last year correct she was oriented to a
different time frame to get a checklist
of those behaviors
and one of the
one of the
the uh
although it says please
how often did this happen in the past
year
one of the questions is
my partner used force to make me have
oral or anal sex
correct she went with zero on that right
i'd have to see if you'd like to show me
you have any recollection that she she
didn't go with zero in that
i have a reelection at that point in
time she was framing those type of acts
as angry sex
she wasn't framing them as physical
force as most women don't on these
measures and you helped her to reframe
it as something other than angry sex
didn't you doctor
my job was not to do treatment my job
was to do an evaluation and that's what
i did
all right um
so you did an evaluation
and
one of the evaluations you did and one
of the
diagnoses that you ultimately made
relates to ptsd that is correct
all right
and you
diagnosed
amber who heard with ptsd
long before
you made use of the gold standard test
for ptsd that is correct
and i make the diagnosis of ptsd in my
clinical practice without using the caps
all the time all right so just that you
and i are on the same page and i think
we are
this gold standard test that i'm
referring to is the caps five that is
correct that's the one that
dr
curry administered correct correct all
right
you didn't administer the cap five
until a after you'd already diagnosed
amber heard with ptsd right
she had ptsd in 2019 she had ptsd in the
beginning of 2021 when i evaluate her
and then she had ptsd in december 27
2021 when i administered the cats that's
correct all right
i think i asked a much more narrow
question than that
you didn't diagnose
you you didn't give the caps five
well i'm going to strike that question
all together and start it again
you
had already diagnosed her with ptsd
before you did the gold standard
correct before i administered the caps 5
there was enough data in the
psychological testing and my clinical
evaluation to establish that she met
criteria for ptsd that is correct
um you
submitted a
expert disclosure in this case on
january 11 2022
i believe the attorney submitted that
disclosure yes you participated in that
in the in the january 11th it was the
same disclosure that went before there
were no changes on that
did you
reference the caps five in that at all
i don't believe i gave the results of
the caps five to the attorneys at that
point
all right
you met with
oh i got dates here
this time i'm using the cheat sheet
all right
you met with abraham on september 26
2019
i would love to have my cheat sheet but
i'll take your word for it
i'll share thank you
11 2019.
when do you give the caps five
the caps five was administered the last
time that i saw miss herd i saw her over
as
stated multiple times over the past two
and a half years and having not seen her
in about a year to get an accurate
assessment of her current symptoms
having had all the background
information the caps five is a great
structured clinical interview to do that
all right you hadn't seen her for about
a year before you
before you gave her that test that is
correct um and you did it overzoo
that is correct
um
why don't we pull up a
px1247
that this may
this is a new one so we don't have it i
just need to know
i'll get you sure
it's just the witness right now
okay okay
sure um
um you could
dr hughes you can actually help with
that question this is like 20 more than
20 pages long it's about 20 pages right
all right
let's get a copy of it
um
this is a series of questions that you
use to test for ptsd
correct
um
and you recognize the first page this is
the first page that you um you filled
out that's your handwriting that's
correct
i'd like to publish the first page to
the jury you wish to have it in evidence
do you moving it into evidence yes i am
i'd like to have a copy of it
he's just publishing the first page any
objection to the first
okay first page in
evidence you put your microphone on i'm
just having
i don't have the ability to scroll down
so i can't see the rest of this it's a
brand new i'm sure they'll get you a
copy of it thank you
i'd like to go to the second page and
can we put up the second page are you
putting the second page into evidence
not yet then i can't put it up oh i'm
sorry
i'd like to i'd like the witness to see
this witness can see the second page
thank you
this is the second page just
instructions on how you do it
correct
all right and then we'll go to the third
page let's let the witness see the third
page
now this
is entitled scoring correct
so when you score
you look at two things right you look at
frequency
and intensity
correct all right those are the two
factors you use to score
correct all right
can we go to the fourth page of this
document and just show it to the witness
all right so
dr hughes this is the first page of the
caps to be
where
other than the identifying information
where where there's any input
into the document correct
the caps five you said the caps b yeah
yes this is the um
the criterion a which means that in
order to as i said yesterday
to obtain a diagnosis of ptsd you have
to have sustained a very specific
dramatic event that's the first key to
get through the door
all right
so
governor i'm going to um i'd like to be
able to get them a copy of this is it is
it too early to take the break or
get a little better all right i can do
something okay yeah
um
all right so
do you recognize the first page or the
fourth page of this document yes i do
and the handwriting on the fourth page
is yours
it's all my handwriting all right the
entirety of it is your i'm gonna move uh
this
document into evidence
along with the first page
and that one is
what number
i think it is
you're still in 12 47 12 47 okay so you
want to move the entirety of 1247 in yes
do you have a copy of 1247
it's exhibit 1247.
well i mean
do you have plaintiff's exhibits 1247.
oh it's defendants 1435
1435
defendant's fourteen thirty-five
did you want to take a look at the
quartz copy would that be easier for you
a it's 59 pages um
what is he moving in i mean i don't
think i think he's moving me and
are you moving the entire document in
yeah i'm going to move the entire
document into evidence
i don't think i have an objection to
that no objection no did you want to
take a look at the court's copy are you
good uh yeah i would thank you
i apologize i'm sorry
thank you jamie
all right so
even though i pulled it from
um defendants 14 35 we want to make this
1247 plaintiffs correct yes your honor
thank you okay
i'll just run away
i kind of need it all right
thank you we'll just change the number
on it
all right all right it says 1247. okay
12 47 in evidence please 12 47 in
evidence and now it can be published to
the jury thank you
why don't we publish the fourth page
where we're talking
about
all right
um
so
what this reference is
is
the event you said was the worst
um and
what you have filled in here
is three words
ipv by john right correct
all right
and then what happened
is the next box
and you've
not written a single thing
in the box right
because i've already spent 20 some odd
hours with miss heard i know what goes
in that box if you look at the top it
says administer the life a check
checklist or another structured trauma
screen that screen had already been
conducted right but there's a box on the
gold standard test
that asks what happened
and
it says how old were you how were you
involved
who else was involved
was anyone seriously injured or killed
was anyone in life danger and none of
that information you provide in your
um
analysis
on the cash flow
i hesitate to object but that's very
compact it is okay i'll sustain the
objection if you want to rephrase we can
do it uh okay the slow way
the first question is how old were you
although the information that would go
in that box is contained in my 80 plus
clinical notes of my evaluation of
misheard up until this point it would
have been incredibly redundant to do
that again here but you knew other
people would review this didn't you
and i knew that they would have my
clinical notes as well oh so they're
supposed to parse through your clinical
notes
so that they can figure out what you
chose to be the anchoring event
i didn't choose to be the anchor the
client chooses to the anchor to identify
what the worst event is for them you
wrote ipv by johnny that's what you
determined to be the anchoring event
when i asked miss heard once again of
the traumatic events that she
experienced in her life which one is the
worst
this is what she indicated
okay
but you provided no details with respect
to
there are d
plethora of details in my 80 page is a
hand written single spaced
clinical notes
all right
let's go to
the next page
all right
you felt
it appropriate
to fill this page out
didn't you doctor
well these are the questions about the
symptoms so i'm asking specific
questions and getting her responses
didn't you know this already
i was making sure at this point having
not seen her for a year what is the
trauma expression at this time
it can change over time it could go away
it can get better it can get worse
right
let me go
a couple more pages in
let's go
into
uh
page
7 of 20.
now
there are a couple of uh boxes that you
filled in on this
let's look at item five
b5
you don't
provide any indication of what kind of
triggers what kind of reminders trigger
these reactions
she answered that on the previous
questions
and you didn't provide any answer as to
how long does it take to recover
she has some difficulty recovering
okay
and then there's this question this is
how often has this happened in the past
month number of times correct
and we talked about how these things are
scored and we looked at you got to look
at frequency and intensity right correct
and you left the frequency box blank
well no she said several times a month
then that's what the frequency is and
you didn't fill that frequency box in at
all
because she told me it was frequently
several times a month which is one of
the anchors encoding the caps all right
let's look at the next one
the very next box
again this is scored by frequency
and intensity
how often in the past month
time
how often in the past month you left
that one blank again right
she tells me it happens at least twice a
week so certainly i could multiply two
times four and put in eight and you
certainly could have written the number
two
but it wasn't two if it's happening two
times a week all right so two times a
week
towards the times the number of
months now you got two digits instead of
one right that's all it took to write
that down this is in in a one month
period so it would have been a four week
period how how often in the past month
that's what it says
correct you said not to answer that
question
uh
let's look at the next page
again scoring is frequency and intensity
how often in the past month
again
you left it blank
if you look on the right hand box that
is where we are indicating the frequency
and the severity if you can see where i
circled moderates happening more than
twice a month that's where i am
indicating the frequency of the symptom
expression
okay
but you're
aren't you skipping a step
you're supposed to do
intensity and frequency
and when somebody says it's happening
more than twice a month that is a
frequency indicator
all right um
let's go
to the next box
again
we have
in the past month how many of the
important parts of event have you
difficulty remembering
number of important aspects
then philadelp well i listed two
specific incidents of where she
indicates she has important aspects that
are missing
but all you have to do is put a number
in here you know you had to you knew how
to score this thing well this measure
actually doesn't get scored by the
frequency all right you know something
you're right let's look at the next one
the next one gets scored by the
frequency that's blank right
well i did not code it as a ptsd symptom
okay let's go to the next one
how much of the time the past month have
you felt that way as a percentage
so as you can see i circled 20 to 30
percent of the time right
i'm putting it on the right side in the
box where i'm coding the instrument
we're going to talk about the right side
in a minute um
you took issue with the way that um
dr curry did this test engine correct
but
your test
in every instance where you're asked the
number of times and to fill in the blank
you leave it blank
they're on the right side of the
documents all right
you want to talk about the right side of
the document let's do that
after you did
the caps 5
for the
uh
anchoring the three-word anchoring event
ipv by johnny
you went back through again and said you
know uh maybe i should consider
childhood trauma as well right i wanted
to test for the limits and see at this
point in time
misheard had had a child and sometimes
when people have children their trauma
gets evoked is she having those symptoms
as well she already had based on this
instrument the ptsd from the
interpersonal violence i wanted to see
if there were any additional symptoms
all right
and you knew that she had had
severe child abuse
as a young person that is correct
she grew up in a home full of heroin
addicts right
opiate abuse yes yeah and uh
and
there was ipv between her parents
correct yeah
and so you wanted to make sure that
there wasn't
some impact with this childhood trauma
in the diagnosis of ptsd
yes right
and so you decided to give her the test
well i didn't give it again what's
called testing the limits i went back to
some of the um
questions where she answered in the
affirmative and said and is this also
happening vis-a-vis your childhood abuse
are you also having intrusive thoughts
and feelings about childhood are you
avoiding thinking about things about
childhood is that happening for you now
as well
all right so there are series
of notations on the right hand side
let's go to page
5 of 20 in the test
all right why don't we highlight the the
right-hand notations that start under
the word childhood
all right
so the way you tested for childhood ptsd
is to write a notation in the corner
and answer a couple of questions same
test
well i wasn't administering a whole caps
again what i was doing was seeing as we
know with people who have what we call
polyvictimization or re-victimization
someone could in fact meet criteria for
the ptsd from the domestic violence but
then they're also experiencing some
symptoms as a result of the childhood
abuse both can occur
right
but mr depp isn't responsible for her
childhood abuse that is correct right
and the way you tested this childhood
abuse ptsd is you made notations
on the right hand corner in the right
hand column
of of a form that you partially filled
out
for the ipv by johnny
right
well i disagree with the partially
filled out the frequency was clearly
filled out in the box where we scored
the caps but yes i did write about the
childhood to the right of that box
and
that is the appropriate way
that the gold standard test
for ptsd for childhood trauma should be
administered
if there were any affirmatives and i
needed to go further i could have
administered another caps five there
were not i did not need to do that
okay
so you chose not to do a second caps
five although you knew that she had
suffered from severe childhood trauma
no because she wasn't suffering symptoms
at that point in time
ptsd symptoms from the childhood trauma
all right
mr dennis are you moving to a different
topic now
okay all right this might be a great
time to take our morning break then all
right ladies and gentlemen uh we'll take
our 15-minute break please do not
discuss this case with anybody don't do
any outside research okay thank you
six
all right we'll go ahead and take
your honor yes take the break yes may i
get a copy of the new exhibits from them
so that i can see it over the break
i don't know if we can do it before but
we'll certainly guarantee you well i
mean i need to be able to uh redirect
and i have never seen these okay we'll
we'll we'll go through it that's fine
all right it's it's although it's in
your exhibit
i think it's in my exhibit list if they
just tell me to tell you the exhibit
numbers that's fine we'll work through
it okay we'll take a let's take a recess
of 1140 then okay
so
all right we ready for the jury
okay
so
do
all right thank you to be seated next
question
why don't we put that
back up please 1247.
um
again this is the
caps five
um
you didn't
administer this until you already had dr
curry's scores did you
that's not correct no
you administered it after dr curry
made a disclosure
correct that's not correct
you administered it
after dr curry
had administered hers
i learned that in late february when she
submitted her report but i had no way of
knowing that in december of 2021
and you didn't make any reference to
this
in your disclosures until after dr curry
made reference to hers right
i don't recall the date of the final
disclosure or the
fourth disclosure
all right can we go to the next page
let's go to the top of the page we'll
blow that up
instructions start with standard
administration and scoring of the caps 5
are essential for producing reliable and
valid scores
and diagnostic decisions
see that language i do
you don't contend it's standard
not to fill out the frequency line
i think if you're filling it on on the
right side of the box i think that's
perfectly fine
all right so
you think it's standard administration
to simply leave
blanks that are already in the form
i didn't leave blanks when i needed to
find out the frequency of the symptoms
all right let's go down a little bit
further
uh
let's go to administration
it says number two
read prompts verbatim
one at a time and in the order presented
and then has a
has a variety of exceptions
with respect
to the childhood trauma notations
you made in the margin of the caps five
you didn't
read the prompts verbatim did you
i read the first prompt if there was a
yes then i would have made a decision do
i need to administer a whole another
caps
right and you ultimately
didn't do that you just simply wrote the
margin of the last one because she
wasn't endorsing those symptoms
okay
um
you talked about endorsement of symptoms
um
ultimately what you're looking for with
respect
to
ptsd is
functional deficiencies it's one of the
things you look for right
well with any
dsm diagnosis you're looking for what
are the functional impairments as a
result of the symptoms that the
individual is experiencing
okay
so
in fact if you go to all the way the end
of the form
one of the
things that we deal with
is
impairment and occupational functioning
right correct
what's ms heard's occupation
she's an actor right
and she's in
she had just wrapped
a major motion picture correct that's
correct
so you didn't determine that she had an
impairment
in occupational function she's still
performing at literally the highest
level of her profession correct she had
a number of ptsd symptoms while she was
filming aquaman too
right that interfered with her
ability to
really organize a lot of resources for
herself in order to go forward and film
that
i asked you whether she was performing
at the highest level of her profession
yes or no
i don't know if i'm qualified to answer
that okay
um
but did she report to you that that she
loves to cook
she loves to cook yes
hike
i don't recall hiking but read
yep spend time with friends
if she can that has been significantly
diminished as a result of her ptsd
symptoms as a result of this case
uh she just had a baby
she did right
exercises every day
the most that i can tell she does yeah
completed level three sommelier training
she did
she did all these things
um
and you've made a determination
that she is impaired with respect to her
occupational functioning
i made a determination that the symptoms
interfere with her functioning she does
these things but it's not like the
symptoms aren't there she has to
continue to work even though she has a
panic attack even though she has an
intrusive recollection of the trauma
even though she's having heart
palpitations and sweaty palms when
something comes into her mind it does
not stop her from doing what she needs
to do but it does interfere
okay
so i'm going to ask you about another
test that you
administered
and that's that one's called the p-a-i
you know that one yes i do
that's the personality
assessment inventory that's correct
okay
why don't we mark uh when we
put in front of the witness the px 1244.
all right
12 44.
thank you
all right
so
dr hughes do you uh recognize uh px 1244
yes
and it's a list of critical item
endorsements
correct
and that's derived from the pai correct
um and this is the pai that you gave
9 26 2019.
i don't have the cover sheet in front of
me so
why don't we scroll down to the bottom
and
there it is
yeah there it is down there thank you
you're better
okay
um
now critical item in one i'm going to
move uh this document px 1244 end
evidence
i would uh request that the entire
document
i'm only going to ask her about this
piece
well it's his it's his exhibit do you
any objection to his exhibit which is
just the first page
all right 12 44 in evidence
okay
so critical item endorsement
this starts a total of 27 pa item p-a-i
items
reflecting serious pathology
have been very low endorsement rates
have very low endorsement rates in
normal samples
these items have been termed critical
items
you're familiar with that concept yes i
am all right and i just want to ask you
about a couple of the critical items
the first one is potential for
aggression
this was deemed under your pai a
critical item
and it says sometimes my temper explodes
and i completely lose control
how did that
uh
potential for aggression
bear on your analysis
well there's a few things number one
certainly misheard reported to me that
in her relationship that would happen
her anger and her affect regulation
would become impaired
number two you have to look at the total
scales where that scale is not elevated
so it would not be a major cause of
clinical concern number three she had
four
responses that she could say to this
question
mainly true very true mainly true
sometimes true or false she chose
sometimes true so she's answering
honestly about her experience
sometimes
it's sometimes true that sometimes my
temper explodes that's what you're
testing correct all right so
you've talked a little bit about this
concept called malingering
and there's one here for potential
malingering
and this is another one of these
critical item endorsements critical
items means that these are
uh serious pathology right
well as you can see it says endorsement
of these critical items is not in and of
itself diagnostic so you need to review
the content of the item
and that's how you make the
determination is this something of
clinical concern that you need to do
more understanding about
okay so this critical item endorsement
this one reads
under potential malingering
i think i have three or four completely
different personalities inside of me
correct and she endorsed that as
sometimes true correct
okay and there's not one elevated
malingering scale on the pai
let me ask you about
another document
all right i'm gonna mark the documents
px488
12 48 12 48.
all right yes sir
okay
all right
thank you
can you put up px 1248 just for the
witness
dr hughes do you recognize this
yes
all right and these are critical items
that were deduced
on the tsi2 critical items list
correct
and
what's a zero mean
means that she scored a zero on that
item she said it's not something that's
relevant for her at the time frame that
the test was administered
um
and these are all self-reports right
correct
um
and so she scored a zero on doing
something something violent because
violent
because you were so upset
correct see that language
you knew
um
misheard to do violent things when she's
upset
this test specifies how often have you
had these symptoms in the last six
months just in the last six months
correct all right so she hadn't had him
in the last six months correct
this test
also asks and inquires about
intentionally hurting yourself for
cutting
in the last six months right
is the prompt sorry in the last six
months correct
had miss heard previously indicated to
you to you that she cut herself
she indicated one time as a teenager in
a reckless moment she did it was stupid
and i never did it again
what
so that was the first time you met her
she indicated that she uh
had cut herself
what did you do to satisfy
yourself that she didn't continue to
engage in that behavior
with most things i asked about the
frequency of the behavior and had it
ever occurred again had she ever engaged
in suicidal behavior or suicidal
gestures that's part of that screen
where did ms heard cut herself
i'd have to look at my notes to be sure
all right
um
why don't we do that
that's in your intake note correct
um
but
i don't recall
why don't we go to px938
and uh if you put it up for the witness
that's not it
let's go to the next page
there we go
all right
px 938 we're on the third we're on the
third page
um
this background information uh sheet
has already been it already been
admitted into evidence
um
and there's a discussion here uh we
talked about earlier
about intimate relationships
i'm sorry the question yeah
let's go back to the first page
all right there we go um
this is in at 12 46. so i
this page anyway i'll ask to be
published to the jury
all right we're going to do it again
what you said 12 46 12 46
all right
okay it's in evidence there's supposed
to be redaction so but okay all right
that's in 1246 all right um
so why don't we blow up the intimate
relationships
section
uh
there's intimate relationships here uh
relative to
a variety of people including a person
called
tasa
tasha tasha
who she
she was miss herd's wife
okay
and that that relationship uh preceded
her
relationship with mr depp that's correct
did you say on direct that you saw no
previous inter-partner violence just yes
or no
i don't believe i did
you know believe that you saw inner
partner violence or you didn't say it on
direct i don't believe i said that
yesterday
okay
you want can we approach it all right
yes sir thanks
did you speak with ms hurd around the
circumstances that gave rise
to the
tro
with um on may 21st yes
yes i did
okay
did miss her ever tell you that james
franco spent the night with her
at the ecb between may 21 and may 27
i recall i mean again it would be
helpful to have my notes so i can tell
you exactly what but i do recall that
she did see him at some point i do not
know if he spent the night
do you know if elon musk spent the night
during that period
i don't know
so
so
you cannot
testify
that johnny depp
was not abused
kenya
i i can testify that he had physical
acts of violence perpetrated on him as
well as psychological aggressive acts
perpetrated upon him
no further questions all right redirect
dr hughes you were asked about some
presentations i think plaintiff's 1241
was the first one if we can bring that
up tom could you help me out with that
12 41.
yes
and if you can scroll down
what was the significance of this
presentation
and and can you can you give her control
of do you have to have control
of the document it's just one page
oh it's not the entire presentation okay
can you please tell the jury what you
provided in this presentation
um to the best of my recollection it was
what i spoke to you about before of how
people who are not trained in forensic
psychology but who are working with
victims of domestic violence can go into
court and navigate with the court system
and present and talk about domestic
violence in a legal setting
okay thank you and that's been moved
into an admission that's been moved in
correct okay well let's go to the one
that i don't think was 1242 please tom
if you can bring that up
all right and is that just one page two
how many pages is that one
okay um
do you recall this presentation
dr hughes yes i do okay um could you
please just well let's i'm gonna move
the admission of plaintiff's exhibit
1242 first of all any objection all
right 12 42. and um could we publish it
to the jury please
and dr hughes could you please tell the
jury explain to the jury what this
presentation entailed
um so i was asked by the
head of the kings county bar association
to give a presentation about intimate
partner violence domestic violence and
how psychological experts can be of
assistance
this was
just because of how brooklyn is a bar
association that was attended by many of
the prosecutors from the kings county
district attorney's office as well as
defense attorneys and as i stated before
this presentation was about how to
really understand cases of domestic
violence how to understand what if she
drops the restraining order what if she
doesn't call the police what are the
myths and misconceptions about intimate
partner violence
and when she uses force what does that
mean how do we understand that how do we
evaluate for that
so again without seeing the rest of the
presentation i believe that was the
thrust of this presentation okay great
thank you
now uh you testified about the notes you
took and the notes you reviewed
and you were asked about some limited
questions on testing i'm going to ask
for defendants exhibit 1434.
thank you thank you
but you were doing a fine job tom i
didn't mean to take it away from you
okay
thank you michelle dr hughes is this
your cv
yes it is all right i'm going to move
the admission of of defendants 1434.
you're out of completeness they've got
all the other records in here for dr
hughes i'm trying to seek completeness i
understand i'll sustain the objection
okay
let's go to uh defendants 1435 please
now dr hughes you've testified about the
different uh
testings that you administered and this
is one of the ones that i believe you
testified to earlier correct that's
correct and this is the dsm-5
um this is the clinician-administered
ptsd scale for the dsm-5 okay
i'm going to move the admission of 1435
any objections
but but she administered all these tests
your honor and they can for completeness
of record they can't put in partials and
then not have the rest of it
well i mean
there was no objection to when they put
theirs in
now they're objecting to
you putting i i would say rule of
completeness you're on a rule to
virginia rule 2 colon 106.
that they can't just put a partial in
and then not not have the completeness
of the testing in the documents well
they put the their test and now you want
to put more tests and correct correct
but that's not a completeness argument
then that's just a different test well
what's the objection though that there's
okay all right i'll sustain the
objection
all right well then we'll go for the
other ones um
you did the tsi
before we go on to the others let's talk
about could you please tell the jury
what you administered in this dsm-5 and
why this is significant
sustain
can you tell us why the dsm-5 is
significant that you administered
so the dsm-5 is the diagnostic and
statistical manual
for psychiatric disorders it's published
by the american psychiatric association
that's where it has all the criteria and
all the information for our major mental
disorders like major depressive disorder
or panic disorder or ptsd what the caps
is the clinician administered ptsd scale
is it follows all of that criteria
that's in the dsm-5 so that you can make
a very accurate diagnosis
and what if any diagnosis did you make
as a result of this dsm-5 right so not
only on this i mean this instrument can
stand alone where she meets ptsd
criteria just by virtue of this
instrument
part of me but also that the other
testing that i gave where she had
elevated scales on ptsd measures which
correspond with the dsm-5 symptoms of
ptsd so there are multiple measures that
are consistent across time that she
meets criteria for ptsd
thank you dr hughes now you were also
given
one page of the scoring on the tsi
two and one page
with respect to the pai do you recall
seeing that
it wasn't the scoring they were the
critical items on those respective tests
okay well i'm going to ask to bring up
defendants exhibit 1858
which is
the full pai
um and was this the actual testing and
scoring
um yes this is the the profile um the
scores that are generated from the 344
questions that ms heard uh answered on
this test and
what did you
what were the results what what did you
determine based on the testing of this
pai
well that the results were valid and
reportable
there was no evidence of exaggeration or
malingering on this test and there were
significant symptoms
that correspond with traumatic stress
and post-traumatic stress disorder
symptomatology
and i believe you said again that there
was um
that there was no elevated scores can
you explain to the jury what you meant
by that objection leading
overruled up okay so elevated scores are
a way that we get to know where a
cut-off is to say that something is
clinically significant and that follows
very um standard statistical principles
so when a scale is elevated it means
that we have sort of greater confidence
that this individual endorse a lot of
different symptoms that make this scale
relevant and that we want to figure out
why
that person is having an elevated score
on something like depression or anxiety
it gives us greater confidence that you
know this person's maybe reporting
depressive symptoms like people who are
depressed
and
what what would constitute an elevated
score
well on different tests it's different
things um certainly on the pai
it doesn't follow linear t-scores it's a
little different statistically so you
have to look at it differently but
certainly you know it's usually about a
t-score of a 65 and on some it's a
t-score of a 70 which is a a t-score is
a normative curve is a way of allowing
us to compare people's scores comparing
your scores to the normative group of
scores okay
and would it be at all helpful to have
the entire test as opposed to a
one piece of paper or one page
well certainly you cannot tell the
entirety of how
the symptoms that misheard endorse and
the scales were elevated just by the
critical items all right i'm going to
move the admission of plaintiff's
defendant's exhibit 1858 objection
hearsay and this is the completeness
your honor i'll sustain the objection
next question
let's bring up 1859
and this is you were shown one page
from the tsi2
the trauma symptom inventory two do you
recall that correct
okay
what is the significance of the tsi to
examine the full exam
the trauma symptom inventory is a test
of common symptoms of post-traumatic
stress disorder and related traumatic
symptomatology and um on this score she
had you know elevations in intrusive
experiences which is the um intrusive
component of ptsd where thoughts or
memories or feelings come into your mind
when you don't want them with
accompanying distress and then the
defense of avoidance doing many many
different things to push it down to try
not to think about it to try not to talk
about it
so that you don't get upset
and she also scored high on a scale of
relational avoidance having difficulty
feeling close in relations and
relationships not only intimate
relationships but friendships as well
and that's a related trauma symptom that
individuals have after having sustained
an interpersonal trauma like domestic
violence
okay
and would it be helpful
to have the full exam as opposed to one
page out of it
as with anything seeing an entire uh
profile give someone more information
you and i had moved the admission of
defendants exhibit 15 for 1859 objection
hearsay and i would argue the completion
now dr hughes you were ass
you were shown a couple of finger
pictures
of mr depp
and i believe you indicated
those were shown to you and i think you
were asked if you were
if these were severe injuries correct
correct all right did you have any
understanding of the cause of those
injuries by mr deb
i do understand that there's competing
accounts of what happened for sure
let's bring up defendants exhibits 373.
you're all right i think this is already
admitted
i don't see it and jamie doesn't have it
so 373 i can mark it
but it's not admitted yet i think
there is a version of that if i may i
don't know that i can just tell you that
373 has not been emitted into evidence
your honor it's not redacted and i don't
believe it's been
the the part i'm trying to admit is in
another exhibit so let's let's go in a
different way we'll take that one down
let's go with 398.
398 redacted isn't evidence that's that
might be the one
all right
if you could
blow that up
and i think we're looking for
if you could move that up michelle
there we go
you can blow that one
this is an email
from mr depp to david kipper his
your understanding was that was his
doctor correct correct
okay
and then i'm going to draw your
attention to
the last part of this this is on 3 19
2015.
thank you for everything
i'm going to figure out how to do this
i'm missing the controls on this
thank you for everything i've chopped
off my left middle finger as a reminder
that i should thank you your honor that
i should never
uh
cut off my finger again do you see that
yes i do okay so that's mr depp
admitting that to dr kipper in 319 2015.
objection leading
okay
i sustain the objection next okay that's
that's fine i'm good with that um let's
go to
defendants exhibit 499.
and your honor i believe this one is in
as well or is it is it the redacted
one
yes that's okay thank you
and then if i could draw your attention
this is a text message from mr depp
to aaron fellotti we talked about her
earlier on 1031 2015
and it says this is the second time he's
held off giving me my meds by
blackmailing me into seeing him the
first time i had just chopped my finger
off do you recall seeing that as part of
the documents that you reviewed
i believe i did okay thank you we can
take that down
now you were also
asked to listen to an audio tape
and it's plaintiffs 343.
i'm going to
and and do you recall here listening to
that audio tape at some point as part of
your review
oh yes i do okay i'm going to now
pull up that same
audio tape
from the same day and i believe that's
june 2016
and if we could go to them we're going
to have a few different ones so so hold
in there with us we're going to start
with
2
minutes 40 seconds 0-0
going to 2 minutes 40 seconds and 21.
i'm knocking on the door because that's
a [ __ ] irrational and violent [ __ ]
maneuver so a man would want to get out
of that area so that he doesn't get so
[ __ ] angry that he actually does pop
the [ __ ] wives
now that was just before the punching
hitting that was played do you recall
that
objection leaving
well
the the tape recording that you listened
to was a 2 colon 4601 to 247 two colon
4720 and that was two colon 40 through
two colon 40 21.
correct i understand objection leading
okay now let's go to after overworld go
ahead thank you now let's go to after
that 2 colon 52
0 0 to 2 colon 52 34.
just yesterday
because of how
it's been lately
like since australia and i have been on
the road with you i haven't been working
i don't know what else i could [ __ ]
do
and i thought everything else was great
and then let's go to 3
colon 20
0 0
2 3 colon 2137
and while they're getting that i'll just
ask you the question dr hughes do you
recall that mr depp said that they had
fights
in
the places that he listed on that audio
tape objection leaving sustained all
right
what do you recall mr depp saying about
fights that they'd had
on that audio tape
um
actually no foundation
she just listened to it
okay yeah i've um i think it was hard to
hear in this one i had listened to it
previously um just acknowledging that
there are fights previously okay
thank you
[Music]
i know
that might mean
[ __ ] egg we do this we make it that
might mean
[Music]
i'll try
[Music]
but done got to get our [ __ ] together as
individuals and as a couple
because i love you
and i do not
majority of the time
i will [ __ ] do everything i can
and i will recognize
do you recall listening to that part of
the tape the audio tape yes i do and
what do you recall from that portion
again i know it's hard to hear but it's
hard to hear but um what i recall from
hearing that was the the negotiation
that the couple is trying to do and and
trying to say you know i'm going to do
my part i'm going to do better
okay is it possible to turn that up
anymore i have one more i'm just
thank you jamie okay my last one is
three colon 26
20
to three calling 29.50
your honor can we approach okay yes sir
when you're ready
what are we going to do different in the
moment when you're mad and you go [ __ ]
it and you decide all bets are off
i put the [ __ ] away
i told
and by a list
of the things that i feel that
[ __ ] you over or make you feel shitty or
anything like that i [ __ ] boomer in
the moment i remember it i remember when
i thought
i remember i try to to
bring it down
not just
many announcements
i'll just try
to if we're heightened
[Music]
i know i need to know what we need to do
different i need to know
what do we do different if i have a
problem you need to tell me how to tell
you different if i'm hurting you
you need to let me be able to be mad
sometimes you're gonna make me mad i'm a
human i cannot live where it's like
it's the same thing goes for me then
you're gonna have to let me get that yes
exactly
it is
i i i i don't have to start yelling i
think i start yelling once it gets
[ __ ] heightened i've gotten a lot
better about that it's just only i only
start yelling when it's [ __ ] hour 11
and we're really in it
sorry about the yelling
you witnessed it you're the one that
brought it up australia was [ __ ]
great you just argued
let's go back there let's go back there
is the monster gone did you put him away
it's been so when you get on that train
you get angry you stay on it for so long
and you won't come down you won't talk
to the person
[Music]
it doesn't have to always be the monster
but what is it can you put that away
can you remember the bigger picture you
don't want to spend your life i've asked
you this so many times in fights you
want to spend your time like this
no you don't but i ask you because this
is something you're choosing i'm saying
to you olive branch
and you don't take my olive branches you
made me feel humiliated for offering
them you asked me to stay in australia i
stayed and then you walk out on me all
the time
you've got to take some olive branches
from me you've got to offer them too
you've got to be bigger than what you
feel at that moment
and so do i
so do i but if i call you on it
you hear it
you call me out on it if i'm doing it
do you remember listening to that dr
hughes yes i do and what is your
interpretation in that what do you
recall
objection
speculation
she's an expert overworld
i think this is more of how this couple
is trying to negotiate in the face of
all of the
um the turmoil and the violence and the
abuse i think it's important pointing
out is my recollection is that there's
two australians they're talking about
the honeymoon australia not the
honeymoon not the australia where the
incident happens they go back and that
becomes a honeymoon time for them um and
i think certainly hearing how
this couple has talked about the monster
and and the person who comes out as we
talked about that cycle of violence
where the person who
you know hurts her and hits her and
controls her isn't the same person that
she she loves and she cares about and
that she wants to be with
thank you dr hughes now
we they you also were asked about dr
bonnie jacobs and
her treatment and her
treatment notes and
you did you review those treatment notes
from bonnie jacobs yes i did i'm going
to ask you to turn to
can we bring up defendants 105 9.
and do you recognize these this document
yes okay
and what is it
um this looks like the first of dr
bonnie jacobs uh treatment notes
starting in october 17 2011. okay and do
you recall whether
ms
heard was already in a relationship with
mr depp at that time
um yes she was okay and you testified
quite extensively yesterday about
bonnie jacobs notes and and entries
there uh were those reflected in these
notes
these were the notes notifications
i can ask it differently and
what if any uh of those uh citations
that you gave to the jury were in these
notes objection compound
overruled okay
um these were the notes that i was
referring to
yesterday
and
what was the significance of these notes
to you you were asked again about them
on cross
i again i found the the treatment notes
very significant because they had
contemporaneous reports of what miss
heard was going through not only what
she was reporting in her relationship
with mr depp but her accompanying
symptomatology
what the notes revealed was there's a
significant amount well we see it unfold
in time we see where the violence starts
and we see how it unfolds we see at
least three indications of sexual
assaults we see
constant
pleadings and and and upset about his
substance abuse and trying to find ways
to get him help and she joins allen on
to get herself help as a family member
of someone who struggles with substance
abuse we see how she's reporting a lot
of controlling behavior and obsessive
behavior
we see that there's two instances where
the police were going to be called and
when in her apartment in orange
because of the fighting
at that time once they actually were
called and once they weren't from what i
could amass from the notes so what it
does is it really shows how this
relationship is unfolding over time and
actually getting worse
and then you indicated that
amber heard moved from bonnie jacobs to
uh dr cohen and that was in 2014 is that
correct correct okay and
what is your understanding of the
relationship between dr cowan and dr
kipper
um they were professional colleagues and
they were friends and um dr i mean well
it's it's understanding why miss heard
left
the relationship with bonnie jacobs it
was it became a tumultuous relationship
for her there because she was doing a
lot to
protect johnny and bonnie jacobs had
concerns objection
what's the objection no foundation
i
established the foundation she reviewed
the notes and she interviewed bonnie
jacobs i'll overrule the foundation
objection
go ahead objection unresponsive
all overall non-responsive please
continue dr hughes um
the reason that um miss heard left her
treatment with bonnie jacobs were one
that mr depp continued to denigrate that
relationship her therapeutic therapeutic
relationship but number two really more
importantly is that she wanted to
protect mr deb because she didn't want
miss dr jacobs had some concerns about
perhaps his substance using in front of
his children and that she would be a
mandated reporter um so miss her did not
want to do anything and talk more about
what was going on with mr um about mr
depp with her therapist for fear that um
something might happen so she left that
treatment really to protect uh mr depp
i'd like to move the admission of
defendants exhibit 1059 the treatment
notes objection here say your honor this
is what we dealt with yesterday your
honor i think that
for completeness here she's has relied
upon these and they reflect the present
sense impressions i'll sustain the
objection to hearsay all right let's go
to defendants exhibit 105.7 please
and dr hughes you also indicated that
you relied on the treatment notes of dr
uh
conan correct cohen connell cohen yes
that's it
okay and and you also interviewed him as
well correct okay and
and on what what was the significance of
what he reported to you that related to
your opinions
well this was a continuation of her
treatment and the treatment here where
it seemed like dr connell cohen was
going was a harm reduction model really
trying to
help amber stay safe in the relationship
by not talking back by leaving by not
engaging
and those are very sort of short-term
strategies when you're in a relationship
mired with interpersonal violence
what we also see is what i mentioned
yesterday is
her psychological status and functioning
continues to deteriorate she continues
to have more anxiety more affect this
regulation sort of feelings are coming
up and down all the time
she's having more sleep problems she's
going on more medication
um and this sort of the
conceptualization and understanding of
that is you know sort of exposure to
repeated trauma
causes psychological disequilibrium and
destabilization um and that's we're sort
of again seeing the trauma unfold over
time
and also in these notes i mean certainly
there are those contemporaneous reports
um that correspond to specific incidents
like i was speaking with you yesterday
about the boston plane incident there
are actual notes where she called him
after objection
yes what's the objection beyond the
scope of the question
all right i think i'll sustain the
objection next question okay
um
what if any uh additional information
did you get from dr cowan that assisted
you in your opinions
um well certainly from the notes as i
was stating that you know there were
times where right after an incident you
know
miss heard wrote um she contacted dr
cohen either by text or by email and
saying you know johnny did a number on
me tonight i really need to see you um
i'm safe objection hearsay
i i think she can rely on hearsay
sustain the objection to hearsay okay
would you rather i'm i'm going to uh
move
the admission of the notes uh defendants
1057
objection here say you're honest
testimony as well
no we'll continue on go ahead thank you
um
you were asked about a knife you were
shown plaintiff's exhibit 92 and a knife
that's i think is till death
what is your understanding of the
significance of that knife and that
phrase as it related to amber hurd
objection you're under no foundation
he was that he showed it in
cross-examination i'm i'm able to ask
about it and what her understanding was
he cut her off when she was trying to
talk i'm just letting her go back in
her understanding of a knife
let's pull up plaintiffs 92 tom can i
get you to do that please
i believe you respond in response to the
questions asked
by council for mr depp you said it
depends upon what the context is what
did you mean by that
well if first i believe that this is the
knife that has a turquoise end um and
this was when a time when mr depp was
filming the lone ranger and he was in a
turquoise phase
and she purchased sim that because she
thought it would be
a kind gift
the phraseology is that mr depp told her
the only way out of this relationship is
death
section hearsay
i
i don't i don't understand the objection
i think she was she was entitled to be
able to speak to that
but she it
yeah it's mr dev's statement the party
opponent
objection thank you okay
um and what is your uh opinion
what do you think of that as a clinical
psychologist in specializing in ipv and
trauma
i mean objection your honor can i uh can
we approach
dr hughes do you think that the
phraseology on the knife
uh there's any relationship or
significance to the opinions you've had
in this case objection
what if any significance
does the phraseology on the knife
have in to the opinions you have
provided in this case
objection your honor beyond the scope of
the disclosure
he brought it up and crossed over
thank you
um so there are several things i i
certainly am aware that at this time
that um
misheard purchased this knife for um mr
depp
she was um engaged in a her whole
lot of denial and minimization about the
extent of the violence in the
relationship
there is a notation in dr bonnie jacobs
notes about
um when mr depp uttered this to her
um was under around the discussions of
the prenup and he said i don't want one
because the only way out of this
relationship is death
dr jacobs didn't think that that was
funny miss heard was taking it like oh
maybe it's endearing maybe this is okay
but it was definitely a clinical cause
of concern
at the time
that that phraseology was used
thank you dr hughes now you were
you listened to an audio tape and then
we showed some additional ones from that
what if any photos did you review as
part of your examination
beyond the scope across
he was asking all the different
authority i'm just establishing that she
also looked at photos i'll sustain the
objection okay let's be honest
dr hughes
based on everything in the
cross-examination and the redirect what
if any changes do you have to any of the
opinions that you provided to this jury
yesterday
objection compound
overrule
i i don't have any changes to my
opinions that i gave yesterday okay
and do you still hold those within a
reasonable degree of psychological
probability or certainty
yes i do thank you i have no further
questions all right is this witness
subject to recall
yes your honor all right ma'am you can't
discuss your testimony with anybody but
you're free to stay in the courtroom
since you base your expertise okay thank
you all right thank you
all right i think we'll go ahead yes sir
okay
all right judy
let's go ahead and take our lunch break
now just not do any outside research and
don't talk to anybody about the case
okay we'll see you back here too okay
all right we'll be back at two then
all right thank you
one
uh
yes
sorry judy
it's been that kind of day
so
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
be seated all right your next witness
your honor we'd like to call laura amber
heard to the standard all right amber
laura
i do
yes all right thank you all right thank
your honor
will you please state your name
yes it's amber laura heard and what is
your address
i live in yucca valley california
and how old are you amber
i am 36 i just celebrated
okay and do you have a daughter
i do she also celebrated her birthday
recently she's won
okay
and what is your profession
i am an actor uh mostly
okay
now
why are you here
i am here because my ex-husband
is suing me uh for an op-ed i wrote
and how do you feel about that
i
um
i
struggle to have the
words i struggle to find the words to
describe how
painful this is
this is horrible
for me to sit here
for
weeks and
relive everything
here
people that i
knew
some well some not
my ex-husband with whom i shared a life
speak
about our lives in the way that they
have
um
this has been one of this is the most
painful and difficult thing i've ever
gone through
for sure
now
there was a
trial in the uk in july of 2020 where mr
depp had sued the sun newspaper and dan
wooten do you recall that
yes uh and what was your level of
participation in that lawsuit in that
trial
well i was
not party to that lawsuit i was
a witness
um i i suppose the primary witness since
it dealt with the truth of
the relationship
that i shared with johnny
and what if any role did you have to
play with respect to for example witness
statements and testifying
objection compound
i said for example
overruled
i had to
write
i think i gave seven witness statements
um under oath testimony
i sat on the stand
for four days
um under mostly cross-examination
and up until this point it was the
hardest thing i had ever had to do
thank you amber
i'm going to take you back and if you
can just tell the jury a little bit
about your background tell us where you
grew up
i come from austin texas a small town
outside of austin that you probably
haven't heard of no one has
called maynard
and i was raised by my mother my father
and i grew up with a little sister
although i have a big sister as well
and your little sister's name is uh her
name is whit wait heard and how how much
of an age difference is there between
the two of you
whitney and i are about one year i think
we're 16 months apart so
right next to each other
and what did your father do for a living
my father
broke horses and did construction had um
he painted houses
and
hunted and fished but that was for fun
and what did your mom do
she worked for the state of texas
let me just since you talked about the
breaking horses can you just tell the
jury what your role is in assisting your
dad on that and what is involved in
breaking horses objection leading
can you just tell me about
overworld good
um
you just gotta stay on basically
uh i
i would help them i was more of a
a crash test dummy you know when you
train a horse you
that
it's a wild animal it doesn't
necessarily like to be
um ridden
and uh
there are people out there um who are
crazy enough like my dad to pick that as
a profession
i guess and
he was really good with horses and
i was the son he never had so
it was my job to
you know stay on
and what if anything did you learn from
your father about
how to react to the horses
well with training horses
i guess the key
the the key things are to not show fear
not get intimidated not show fear
be tough and calm
tell the jury a little bit about your
educational background during those
growing up years and your work
experience
i worked
any job that i could from the time i was
really young i
wanted to
get out of texas and do something with
my life and see things and do things
so
i was in school and really pushed myself
to
i just always pushed myself to
be able to
accelerate the process i wanted to
you know get out of school as fast as i
could and i wanted to do
i wanted to
do more things with my life and stay in
texas
so what types of things so where did you
go to school
i was a scholarship kid at a catholic
school um growing up uh several
different catholic schools but they were
always in the
other you know on the other side of town
in the
wealthier part of town and i grew up
quite
working class
and
and and thankfully with um
you know
as long as i maintained an a average i
i enjoyed the benefit of a scholarship
and
i did that until i realized that i could
take my ged and sats early and i did
that and placed out of school and
effectively left school 16 years old i
believe
and what did you do for work during
those younger years
i took any job that i could i worked at
my father's construction company
sometimes
you know just
administrative stuff i mean it was a
small company um
but i answered phones and
i
worked at a modeling agency that was
also
you know
offered photography classes makeup
classes hair
hair and makeup classes for people that
were
pursuing a career in entertainment
and i
started
taking
classes that i paid for by working there
effectively as a trade
uh and i eventually worked there long
enough to be able to pay for my head
shots which are the pictures that you
use in the industry to
promote yourself you know in
in whatever
acting modeling or both
okay
and what if any charitable work did you
do when you were still young
it started off as a requirement for the
school i went to and then
i liked it so much i think because it
it meant i wasn't at home and that was
important to me is just to not spend
time at home
and i
um i really i really loved meeting
people so i worked at the soup kitchen
every morning before school um during
the school year
uh for about four years
there were i didn't go on weekends but
on weekends i would do
various things worked at children's
like
children's
museums typically because they would
work with younger volunteers
and mostly soup kitchens and things
involving children i worked at the
with deaf kids for a while and
yeah i love it
and when you worked with deaf kids what
if anything did you do to learn to be
able to work with them
objection leading and 404
and relevance
overruled
well i
i taught myself how to sign basic sign
language and then i um
i pursued it i audited a
a translate
a course at the community college which
i ended up going to
to get out of high school early
later on but i would audit classes the
teachers never wanted to kick the
you know random 12 year old out of their
class i suppose so i remarkably was able
to audit
i think
the majority of two semesters and that's
also
helped me learn
so how did you end up in los angeles
i
use i met i did it i did a small job in
texas where
i played a part in a movie and the actor
in the movie that i was playing opposite
had an agent visiting him from la
and i
met her on set and she said that she'd
heard about me from another bit part i
did you know i was taking jobs in austin
for really anything to be an extra to
apply my i did makeup once i
you know nothing no job was
too
small or you know for me so i i put
myself out there and she had heard about
me and she said
i have heard about you in this town and
i'd love to meet you in la if you're
ever out
in l.a and i was like um
when can i come
and she
made an appointment with me for the
following week and i used
all but 180 or something
um to get out there and that's i landed
i didn't know anyone i was 17
and
i've effectively ever been there ever
since i suppose so when you arrived in
hollywood please tell the jury what you
did to get moving there get going
i
went to every audition
every casting every meeting every
appointment that i could i i put myself
out there i didn't have a car
because those were expensive
so i took the bus around la it was
before smartphones i had a
thomas guide
in my bag and a change of tank tops um
not that it mattered but
i went to about
10 auditions sometimes a day and would
change clothes if i needed to in the
back of you know the bus i was taking
and i just
hustled from one audition to the other
and uh i got a bit part on one thing and
then i got a bit part on another thing
and then eventually
my roles kind of
became more important or bigger and
um
it's been a slow progression i guess
since then you know of doing either tiny
bit parts in bigger movies
or doing
you know larger roles in movies that no
one would see
and i guess you know it still is kind of
like that
so i'm going to ask you to go from 2002
to 2009 if you could just describe for
the jury a little bit what types of
parts you had
i think
they've indicated they didn't you you
have not been well known here in this
courtroom compared to mr depp so perhaps
just take them through a little bit of
that yeah that's fair um
i did small roles in big films like
zombieland and um
pineapple express and
movies that were well known
my first one was friday night lights
but again i had small roles in those
bigger films and then i would do larger
roles in
um kind of
smaller films like
i
brought um i did a project where i was
the lead in a john carpenter film and he
came out of retirement to do that
and that's kind of
the how it was in terms of my career for
those initial
that first initial 10 years or so it was
just
going from slightly bigger role to
slightly bigger role and
just working my butt off
so i'm going to take you up to 2008 did
there come a time that you auditioned
for the rum diary
yes i um
i auditioned for that in about 2008 i
believe please describe for the jury
your experience in auditioning for the
room diary
well i auditioned a few times which is
common in my work you know um you get a
call back as they say and i think i had
at least one maybe two callbacks
with the director and then i got a call
saying that johnny who at the time was
i think i knew that he was producing it
as well um
was doing a project that was
something very personal to him he was
reprising his role as his late friend
hunter s thompson
and it was a very important project to
him and that he wanted to meet me in
person
i thought i would be going for maybe an
audition
but it was just a meeting i went to his
office
and met with him for a few hours and
what did you talk about during that
those few hours
we talked about books
and music
poetry
and we like a lot of the same
we liked a lot of the same stuff you
know obscure writers and you know
interesting books and
pieces of poetry that i haven't
heard anybody else reference or know or
like and he
was very well read and charismatic and
you know i think i left the office with
a few books that he gave me and we spent
the whole time just
talking about
things that we care about and i was
i was so surprised that somebody you
know
i knew who he was i wasn't
familiar you know i wasn't a fan of his
work i wasn't familiar with him but i
knew who he was you know he's one of the
most famous people in the world
so it was already a weird thing to go
and get called into his office and
you know i'm a no-name actor i was 22 i
think and
i thought it was unusual
it was weird because he's
it was
twice my age and he's this world famous
actor and here we are getting along
about
obscure books and
weird you know
old blues and
we just
it was i thought it was remarkable you
know i just hadn't really
i thought it was unusual and remarkable
i left there just
feeling like wow
so did there come a time that you
learned that you were going to be cast
for the role in the rum diary
yes a few days later my agent um said
that
johnny's going to call you we gave him
your phone number
i was like oh okay
and shortly after i my phone rings i
pick it up and i hear you know this like
deep
voice on the other line and he said you
got the you know you're a kid you're the
you're the dream hunter wrote this part
and
you're the dream you're right kid
and amazed please describe for the jury
what that means what what was the rome
diary in this hunter thompson what was
the concept here and what role were you
playing
um well it was my
understanding that he was bringing to
life
his late friend
and what he told me was that
this character is supposed to be the
dream woman like the dream american
dream and
um
so i knew what he meant he indicated to
me
when he told me i got the role that i
was i was that you know then he
i was the dream kid that's what he said
so did there come a time that you
started filming the rum diary
yes i'm not quite sure how much
i think we started filming in
maybe march of 2009
and where did you film the rum diary
we shot it in puerto rico
and describe if you can
the events of the filming and your
interactions with mr depther in that
time
it was a bit surreal you know uh filming
in a place like puerto rico it was
beautiful um it takes place in the 50s
so everything
really looked beautiful and you know
cars and clothing
the music it was just it was a very
colorful
um shoot
in general i
i i couldn't have asked for you know a a
better scenario i i was on on film i
mean i was on set
um reading
my books and occasionally johnny would
talk to me and then he started to be
really kind to me
like more open with me
uh when we'd have hot days filming
you know there'd be this big suv pull up
and
a security guard would kind of usher me
into this car and it would have the ac
blasting
and i'd be sitting in the back of the
suv
just thinking what a strange experience
the whole thing was and
you know
we didn't really have a whole lot of
interaction
on set
until
um
until we
did a scene that involved um kissing we
had a kissing scene and
it didn't feel like a normal
it didn't feel like a normal scene
anymore it felt
it felt more real
there are certain things that you do in
the job
to
um be professional like when you have to
do that sort of
scene
and you don't like
you
you don't use your tongue if you can't
if you can avoid it there's certain
things that you do to just
maintain a certain line and it just felt
like those lines were blurred i mean he
grabbed my face and pulled me into him
and really kissed me
but we were filming a scene
did he use his tongue
yes okay did your birthday did you
celebrate your birthday while you were
in puerto rico
i did i celebrated
i think
maybe my 23rd birthday there
and what if anything did mr depp do for
your birthday
well we were already kind of
talking about books and poetry and
things like that he gave me a few really
beautiful poetry books
and
he gave me a bicycle uh like a vintage
bicycle because at the time i was riding
around on a bike and i had a lot of time
off since i was a smaller role in the
movie
and um
yeah i think that was it okay
now did there come a time that um you
ended up
visiting him in his trailer
yes um
i think there was a we would hang out if
you know after
or in between scenes or in between
setups we often were
you know talking about things and would
continue the conversation into the
trailer um often with the director bruce
robinson was his name
um
and then at one point we talk about wine
it's another thing that johnny and i
shared in common i love for uh wine red
wine uh and we were talking about
um a kind of wine that i enjoyed and i
was
you know going on about how great this
bargain wine was and
i didn't understand you know how much
more sophisticated johnny's taste and
wine was um so i was going on about the
virtues of malbec or something and i
brought him a bottle
of this wine and i
set it down and at some point i'm i'm
going back to get back to set and he
kind of
kicked his like you know foot up in the
air and
basically kind of lifted the back of my
bathrobe up and
can i just stop you there why were you
wearing a bathrobe because i was doing a
scene
it was a period film so it took place in
the 50s and so i had all of this um
old undergarments that are for that time
era um on
and the scene involved me changing um
so i had all the costume on and he kind
of
picked up the back of my robe with his
boot
and i kind of turned around and
like laughed like giggled you know
um
i wasn't i didn't feel
i just didn't like i didn't know what to
make of it at the time and it just kind
of i just kind of giggled and
batted away playfully and uh
he he
kind of playfully kind of pushed me down
on this like bed sofa
uh that was in his trailer just playful
um and flirtatious and he said uh yum
and he kind of like lifted up his
eyebrows like that
and i
just giggled
laughed it off kind of batted him away
and you know
moved on went back to set
and were you in a relationship at that
time i was okay and was mr depp in a
relationship at that time that was my
understanding yeah okay uh and did
anything else of significant happen
during that that time period while you
were filming with mr depp other than
what you've told us
we just had this
you know it was a friendship flirtatious
thing we i
felt chemistry i felt this
other thing that was that went beyond
the pale of my job
for sure
johnny
clearly felt that way about me had
indicated to me that that's how he felt
in many different ways and
but at the same time that's
you know we were both in relationships
and it is a job and
you know i it was intimidating and i
just remember feeling kind of
intimidated and
a little nervous about that and i also
was in a relationship so we went our
separate ways and we didn't hear i
didn't hear from him
for a long time
and that's so approximately how long
were you filming in puerto rico for the
rome diary a few months is my best
and when you left puerto rico in the
filming
when is the next time that you had any
contact from mr depp
and contact could include
anything like communications written
communications as well as
telephone or otherwise
we had no contact until
johnny called me on the phone one day
and i was driving and he invited me over
to his home in in california in beverly
hills
and i um
[Music]
i was out of the blue i didn't even have
his phone number
so i was it was quite unexpected
uh he called me a second time but i i
don't think we actually connected or we
didn't stay on the phone um because
we did well yeah we didn't really speak
but the first time was the only time i
actually spoke to him and he invited me
over to his house
uh under kind of the
he said that you know we could get bruce
who is the director to come over
something about the movie
but it was clearly not about the movie
if you know what i mean it was
so i said um
i said my friends are in town
uh and i'm i'm busy with that and kind
of hung up feeling really
startled me you know that didn't know
what else to do what if any gifts did mr
depp send you during that time period
after you filmed the rum diary
uh he sent me
several gifts he sent me a beautiful
dress
one that i wore
in the movie
uh with a beautiful handwritten note
said happy wrapping
and um
made a reference to the dress being
wrapping paper
uh
he sent me a few
gorgeous expensive
what i can only assume are expensive
collectible books uh items
uh and then when i was away filming on a
different
you know a different job
he uh attempted or he did send me
some guitars
uh i know one delivery
i was informed about one delivery um and
i my partner at the time
uh intercepted the the the attempt to to
deliver and called me immediately and
said what should i do and i say well sen
i said send it back and she did and
she indicated that there was at the time
there was another one
that had already previously attempted
delivery and it was also rejected we
sent it i sent it back
because i wasn't there and i wouldn't
have accepted it anyway
okay
did there come a time that you ended up
having to go on a press tour for the rum
diary
we i got a call for the rum diary press
tour in
the fall of 2011. so that's close to two
two and a half years after you filmed
um
i'm an actress not a mathematician for a
reason
roughly yes okay and um
could you please describe for the jury
what a press tour is just explain it to
him when you take a
movie once it's completed and uh if it
doesn't have distribution you as part of
the promotion of that movie you go to
these various
places normally cities
like london or
new york and you
do press events in those cities to kind
of promote the film and you go to place
to place talking about the film
and so
you were then called to participate in
the press tour for the rom diary
uh yes i had um just
i was going i just finished going
through the process of uh separation
with my former partner
and i was moving and
going through that and i got a phone
call saying
remember that movie you did in puerto
rico well they want you for the
press tour and
i said well perfect timing
and we did that i think october late
october 2011. okay so describe for the
jury your interactions with mr depp
during the press tour
well on the first stop of the first stop
the beginning of the tour was los
angeles where we both lived and
we did a press day
normal press day and then at the end of
it
i was invited uh by johnny to come up to
his room
to have a drink with uh him and the
director
of the film
and i
went up to the room um to see both him
and bruce um but
as soon as i got there johnny said bruce
wasn't going to make it so i stayed
johnny and i started talking
i told he asked me about my relationship
i said well you know i'm going
going through it um
i'm going through the separation right
now and it's been
you know rough couple of months but
that's normal and he said well that same
with
same with me you know it's been
i can't remember exactly how long he
said it had been but that he had split
from the mother of his kids and
said that he understood
all right and then what happened next
uh then we drank red wine
and continued to talk
and
the talking became us
you know
reconnect you know it was like
reconnection was almost instant um
it was just chemistry
it's hard to explain that but we sat on
the couch and we talked and
um
you know it felt like there was uh
it felt like there was an electricity to
the room and that's how i felt when i
was alone with him anyway and it was
instant again i was like whoa
so
on the on the couch we we talked
finished some wine and then i got up and
left and as i went to leave
he
grabbed both sides of my face
similar to what he did
in in puerto rico and we were filming
that scene
and
he kissed me and i kissed him back
and
what happened next with respect to any
relationship with mr depp
well then we fell in love
we went on this press tour
and
we went
it was it was a beautiful and strange
time you know we went from we're flying
from one not together but you know going
from one city to the next europe
um new york los angeles as i said and
we're just
traveling around talking about this
movie that we did together that we
participated in together
and
we were falling in love i mean it was
just you know at the first dinner in
london he
sat me next to him you know he produced
the film and was a part of
controlling the film and was responsible
for different things and i was as a
small
as an actor having a small partner and
we went on this press tour and
i think in london he sat
he had me sat next to him at this at a
dinner and then we ended up spending the
night together in my hotel room
and
for the rest of the
press tour we were
it was on i'll put it that way
all right
and
how long approximately did the press
tour go
i don't know exactly how long it lasted
uh i think you know there were
press engagements in this city for a few
days and then another city for a few
days
and then
there was a break and then there was
another press opportunity i believe so
it was kind of spread out over
over maybe
a month if i'm guessing
so when you return to los angeles what
if anything
took place with any relationship with mr
depp
well
once we were back from the press tour
you know we had this
you know whirlwind romance kind of just
in these like beautiful places all over
and
we're falling in love and not able to
really show it because um
he wasn't
that the world didn't know about the
split between
he and his former partner and of course
um
some woman i was like is that
troubling you know and i i'd ask him
no you know he swore to me that they
hadn't even shared a bed for a year and
that they were but they were protecting
the kids and not publicizing it so or
not making it known to the press and so
we kind of had to be a little bit under
the radar not a little bit we had to be
really under the radar
um because as
johnny pointed out that the world would
blame me
um and call me a homewrecker uh even
though i had nothing to do with it
so we were secretly dating and then
you know it was it was it was beautiful
it was um
i
felt like
this man
knew me and saw me in a way that no one
else had
i felt he understood me i felt he
understood
where i came from i i felt like
i felt that like when i was around
johnny i felt like the most beautiful
person in the world
you know it made me feel seen made me
feel
like a million dollars
and
that kind of
feeling where you know he just
lavish gifts and lavish expressions of
love and how he had never met a woman
like me i mean i remember he took
the foil off of the
off of this uh bottle and put it on my
ring finger and i had only been with him
like
days you know or maybe maybe it was
weeks at the time yeah it was probably
about a few weeks but it just felt very
intense but we weren't doing normal life
stuff we weren't like
stuck in traffic with each other we
weren't going to the grocery store and
doing life we were like
hiding in these places
around the world he had a lot of he has
so many homes and so we'd be in one of
those homes or my home at the time and
it would be like a bubble like a ins
like we were in this little bubble of
secrecy and it felt like a warm glow as
we would say
just music and and the kind of
books that we both loved and
poetry that we both knew by heart and it
it was um
it felt like an
it felt like a dream
it felt like
absolute magic
so
while you're
dating i take it you're dating at this
point right
yes
falling in love you're also dating right
okay yes um
did there come a time early on that you
ended up going to his bahamas island
yes uh so shortly after you know i think
started dating october of 2011 and
you know as i mentioned this bubble you
know where he'd come over to my house
and not leave for
like three or four days you know just
smoking cigarettes and playing music and
reading poetry to me or painting me or
you know just
talking um
and then he would
disappear
and there'd be just no way to get a hold
of him no way to contact him
at first i didn't really think anything
about it but um he disappeared
uh at one point uh
and then came back and said he was
dealing with something some health issue
and would i join him in the bahamas
and
that i think that's when i learned he
had an island
and
i was on a trip with a friend of mine in
spain
and i
it was for the holidays and i kind of
re-routed my trip to so i could come and
land in la instead of i mean
landing in miami instead of la so i
could go and meet him on the island and
he had
keenan come and meet me on that um
on that trip like in in miami i get off
one plane get on to another and go and
join him on his private island
and
i noticed he was drinking becks
and
uh tea
like lots of tea
like lots of tea
and i i didn't foolishly think anything
of it um i just you know thought the man
really seriously i missed it before but
really
really loves tea
and we had this beautiful
i don't know less than a week probably
um trip in the bahamas a private island
beautiful
sandy beaches scene
it's a scene that
you just don't i had never experienced
anything like that
um it was a beautiful place a beautiful
time
and uh
we fell
i fell head over heels in love with this
man
so
after the bahamas
i assume you came back
and we're talking are we talking now
early 2012
yes that's correct okay so what were you
doing work wise
while you were dating him in this early
stage
what i always do i would be taking job
to job to job going from
one movie to the next
um mostly not filming in la so
weirdly you live in la to go shoot on
location in other places so
when i was in town
we would go back to this bubble
like insular bubble with
beautiful blaringly loud music and no
one else and nothing else and then
you know i'd go off to to work
and so did he well eventually he left to
shoot lone ranger i believe
okay
now we've heard a little bit about lone
ranger and that that's about mid 2012 is
that right when he was shooting that
that sounds right mid 2012 yeah and were
you shooting anything at that time
i was shooting um
i believe i was shooting machete kills
and austin i had a small part in a
robert rodriguez film that shot in
austin
uh but you know
i think johnny was shooting and then
having some time off and there was just
a lot of travel a lot of movement so
okay and and so what if any visiting did
you do with johnny while he was on his
set for lone ranger and where was he
well he was filming all over the
southwest and at some point i came to
visit him and uh on one of his locations
and i would stay in the house because i
couldn't really
you know occasionally i would leave with
his security guards but i i didn't
really have anything to do but visit him
for a few days so i'd cook
and
kind of stay at home and paint or
whatever and wait for him to come home
and have dinner ready and
um
it was we would have these little
bubbles but kind of scattered throughout
the southwest and as he was filming and
at the time um johnny had you know when
i first arrived at one of these
locations it was the first time that
johnny told me
that he had had a health issue
um something with his liver
and that he wasn't
that's why he was not drinking
um he was drinking a lot of tea
like a lot of tea
okay and so
we've heard a little testimony about
boots what if anything did you do to
help johnny with his boots
well i mean
i um i suppose that i took off his boots
uh and it made an impression on him and
i would i was happy to you know anything
i can do to
to show love
certainly
how i felt about him but if he wanted to
take off his own boots he certainly
could
did you buy mr depp any knives during
that time period
objection leading sustain what if any uh
what if anything did you do with respect
to knives during the time period you
were with him in the lone ranger
objection leading
what if anything
overruled i
johnny had a thing for turquoise and
that eventually you know being in the
southwest it happens really it can
happen really quickly i also too
really love turquoise and
he has a
he loves knives he loves a lot of things
when johnny loves things he does it a
lot and lots of it
uh so he had these daggers that he had
given me that really they were beautiful
in design um
and
uh
they're
you know long curved daggers
and he just talked a lot about knives
had a knife and gun collection
and was quite proud of it and at some
point i i don't really remember exactly
when it was but at some point it picked
up a what i thought was a really
beautiful turquoise handled um
knife and i had it engraved with a
saying
that johnny would say to me all the time
which i
you know
thought was romantic
as funny as that is to say now
and what was the expression the saying
uh until death uh um hasta la muerte in
spanish
now by the time that you're visiting mr
depp in
during his shooting of uh lone ranger in
the june through august 2012 time frame
what if any relationship has he
developed with your family
oh well starting really early on
johnny was
so kind
so generous to my family but especially
especially my mom and dad he just really
he met my dad and um
my dad's a big personality uh he's a
rowdy guy
and
uh
johnny just all of a sudden i had never
noticed you know johnny have a southern
all of a sudden johnny had the southern
accent and was really like buddy buddies
with him and they really
seem to get along
very well they're you know just like
instantly he was giving my dad gifts he
gave him guns he gave him knives they
had this
i mean johnny just really just showered
my dad and my dad's a working man you
know um
salt of the earth guy and he was just
like you know floored he's getting all
these
amazing gifts and being invited to come
on to these locations and you know
johnny's this big movie star and my dad
was just like
you know i think my dad would have
married him himself not
if i hadn't and he just instantly
he gave my mom jewelry brought her out
to come and see me while i was visiting
johnny
uh on on
lone ranger in in some part of the
southwest i think it was colorado
he gave her this beautiful turquoise
necklace and i mean
yeah they were they were
definitely um taken by him
and what if any uh relationship had mr
depp forged with whitney by this time
your sister
i believe the relationship
came a little bit later as they got to
know each other but he did the same
thing with my sister and just really
found um
a bond with with them that
you know
was it was you know he he tried to
do anything and everything he could for
to make them feel like
special and they did you know my mom my
dad and my sister
and what if any relationships did
mr depp form with your friends
johnny's
so generous and can be this really
like overly generous almost you know
like showering you with
gifts and
compliments and just i mean like
you know and he has access and means to
really
you know we're not talking about giving
you a card we're like talking about just
these like extravagant trips or these
extravagant gestures and it's
it's a lot he did that with my close
friends i'm relied heavily on on my on
my friends
and had a pretty
strong support network with them and he
really just
showered showered them with generosity
and love and
light and invited them to come to these
exotic places and flew
people here and there i mean he's
incredibly incredibly generous
so going back to the filming of the lone
ranger what if anything did mr depp do
with respect to
a horse
objection leading
what if anything overruled okay
uh
johnny at one point insisted on
buying me a horse
and i of course said that's ex
extravagant
there's no way i could accept that
that's
how also how will i take care of that or
you know it's just so extravagant so i
said no of course eventually
he got a hold of my dad
and
worked it out with my dad what kind of
horse to buy and then showed me a
picture of this horse and said
it's yours
it's it's it's coming here i think it
was being
transported and he said you know that he
had my dad's help on it picking out you
know i grew up on on my dad's
horses and i grew up riding with my dad
so
you know i i went i had i had um
resisted for i think about like a month
and a half or something of him kind of
bringing up the idea and me saying
that's
a crazy gift no thank you no that's
incredibly generous but i couldn't
accept to all of a sudden i had a cult
so um
so let's let's take you through
2012 and your relationship could you
just describe for the jury a little bit
about how that relationship evolved
through 2012.
it was always intense it didn't become
intense it almost started that way
um
i
when i was with him you know
i
i felt that electricity in my body i
felt like butterflies that couldn't
you know
i couldn't see straight practically it
was just
you know i had i
was head over heels and love and
he felt like that to me he he felt like
he was also in love i didn't feel like
he was
faking it i felt like we what we had it
felt like to me at the time there wasn't
any love like that you know i mean
and then
he would
he started to kind of do this thing
again where he disappeared
and he'd come back and i remember
at first he would when he first started
drinking i didn't really think
much of it but all of a sudden the
behavior kind of started to go in line
with the disappearing and he'd come back
and he'd just be different
and i'd say something and
he'd accuse me of saying something else
or saying it in a different way or he
would um it was mostly my clothing at
the time and me working that was the
main thing like
i found myself
trying to
not
talk about auditions because it was
it would change the mood so dramatically
i i tried to
you know he would make these comments
about
you know
whoring myself out but do so in the
context of
me acting
you know and he would talk about other
actresses who do my role
in this way where they were
worthless [ __ ] that they were they
were you know uh
fame hungry
you know expletive expletive you know
just this
the point is it felt really dirty to be
an actor
never mind that he was one
it was more it was dirty that i wanted
to do this job that i wanted to do and i
was doing the job of an actress it was
everything i
every
time i was walking out of the house i
he would ask me that's really what
you're wearing kid oh i see
you know i wore a dress to an event once
and
i felt i felt beautiful in it
like stupid as that sounds i i felt
pretty in this
dress i picked out and
i showed him because i you know it's a
carpet it's red carpet so it's like you
know publicized and i kind of thought it
was weird he didn't
wasn't saying anything about it you know
i left him to go do this red carpet
and i
was like did you see the the
you know the event i went to you know
basically i just i i felt pretty and i
thought like did you see that you know i
wanted him to say something about that i
guess
and um
and he said
well
this is after he
stopped talking to me for some time
didn't tell me why when he came back in
my life he wouldn't explain
why he was acting different he just kind
of acted mad at me i didn't know what i
had done wrong and when i brought up the
dress and the event because it was an
event to support a charity i was really
involved with at the time
and
i said you know did you see that thing
and he said yeah yeah i think the whole
world saw that kid
that's how they'll remember you that's
how the world will remember you
i was like
oh come on i mean it's like but it you
know i felt i felt good in it i felt
good and he said yeah kid that's what
you're putting out there in the world no
one will ever forget that and that's all
they'll see you as that's what you
that's what you wanted that's what you
were going for you know my
dress was slow cut i get it slow cut
but i felt
um you know
i felt really embarrassed and horrible
that i wore that i felt like how could i
have
made that choice of course you know he's
right you know you start to believe it i
i started to believe that that made a
lot of sense of course um
but it didn't stop with that it was just
it was
clothing in general and when i walked
out of the house it was never it wasn't
just like hey you're not allowed to wear
that it was like
oh really
that's what you're wearing no wonder no
wonder you get cast in those roles no
wonder you
you
that's what you are that's what you're
making it
and it just it you know it continued and
then
then there would be a blow up
and
at first it was just to throw something
smash some things
um
it loves to smash up a place an
apartment furniture is what it started
with glass threw a glass at me and i
remember it was summer
um
and he just threw this glass across the
kitchen and i it didn't hit me but i i
it shattered behind me and i remember
thinking that it like very easily could
have hit me
and
that
calling me a horror
it didn't start with using the horror
word it was just
comments
until it would escalate
and then i started to notice the pattern
of escalation where he'd
throw glass or turn over a table
then he would hit the wall and then he'd
hit the wall really close to my head
you know like when i'm standing there
you know just hit the wall screaming at
me
um
but
then he would um disappear
and get clean and sober and he'd come
back and tell me
that he
was done drinking he was over it he was
done cleaned himself up he had done it
before and he'd do it again
and then he would go back to this like
wonderful like
almost like
just unreal
like real you know but un
unbelievably
nice sensitive kind warm generous
interesting funny man that i loved
and he would make me feel so
loved like it would get
i would feel so distant from that thing
that was so scary
that i would
not even recognize it too and that was
how you know our relationship kind of
started to develop in that first year
do you remember the first time that he
physically hit you yes please tell the
jury about it
it was so
it's seemingly so stupid so and like
insignificant
i will never forget it
i changed
it changed my life i was
sitting on the couch
and we were talking we were having a
like a normal conversation you know just
there was no fighting no argument
nothing
and um
he was drinking and
um i didn't realize at the time but i
think he was using cocaine because it
was like there was a jar a jar
of cocaine out on the table
i realized that sounds weird but it was
like
an actual vintage jar of it
but i didn't see him use at the time so
i didn't really factor that in i just
you know he's drinking and we're talking
and it's there's music playing and he's
smoking cigarettes and we're sitting
next to each other on the couch
and i asked him about the tattooias on
his arm
and to me it just looked like
black marks like i didn't know i didn't
know what it said it just looked like
muddled faded tattoo that was hard to
read
and i said what is it what does it say
and he
um said it says wino
it says why no and i
i didn't see that i thought he was
joking
uh because it didn't look like it said
that at all and i laughed
it was that simple
um i just laughed because i thought he
was joking
and slapped me across the face
and i laughed
i laugh
because i
i didn't know what else
to do i thought
this must be a joke
this must be a joke
because i'm
i didn't know what was going on
i just stared at him
kind of laughing still thinking
that he was gonna start laughing too to
tell me it was a joke but he didn't
he said you think it's so funny you
think it's funny [ __ ] you think you're
a funny [ __ ]
and he slapped me again
like
i was clear
it wasn't a joke anymore
and i stopped laughing but i didn't know
what else to do
you know you
i i i didn't know what to do you you
would think you would have a response
but i as a woman had never been hit like
that
i'm an adult and i'm sitting next to the
man i love and he's slapped he slapped
me for no reason it seemed like and i
missed the point it was that stupid
second slap i know he's not kidding but
i don't know what else to say or do so i
just stared at him i didn't say anything
i didn't react i didn't move or
freak out or defend myself right or
say what are you doing you're crazy i
just stared at him because i didn't know
what else to do
and he slaps me one more time hard
i lose my balance
at this point we're sitting next to each
other on the edge of the couch i was on
the edge of the couch
and
i'm
all of a sudden
realizing that the worst thing has just
happened to me
that could possibly happen to you i
realized that i
i wish so much he had said he was joking
because it didn't hurt
didn't physically hurt me i was just
sitting there on this on on this carpet
looking at the dirty carpet wondering
how i wound up on this carpet and why i
was
never why i never noticed that the
carpet was so filthy before and i just
didn't know what else to do i didn't
know what to say i didn't know how to
react i just
sat there thinking how much time do i
have to i figure out what i
need to do because god did he just hit
me
no i didn't want to leave him i didn't
want this to be the reality i didn't
want to
have the man i was in love with
i know you don't come back from that you
know not dumb i
i know you can't hit
a woman i you can't hit a man you can't
hit anyone you can't just
hit somebody because they
i knew there was no i knew it was
wrong and i knew that i had to leave him
and that's what broke my heart
because i didn't want to leave him
i thought if i got up out of that room
and i would leave the best thing that
ever happened to me
and i wish i could sit here and say i
stood up and i walked out of that house
and i drew a line and i stood up for
myself
[Music]
it's just looking at the
dirty carpet trying to will myself to
get up
to walk out
of the door because i knew i needed to
and i really slowly
i stood up and i remember looking at him
in the eye and just looking at him
frankly because i didn't know what else
to do
and before i know it he
starts crying
and you know like i i have never seen
an adult man cry
i didn't really see my dad cry at my
grandma's funeral you know just it's
weird
and he's crying
tears i mean just falling out of his
eyes he gets down on his knees and he
grabs my hands and he's touching my
hands and he's
saying to me i will never do that again
i'm so sorry baby i i put the [ __ ]
away i thought i killed it and it's it's
done i i ki
i thought i'd put the monster away
and i've done it before it's done
but on his knees
and i
i i didn't have words i didn't know what
to say i just remember thinking that
it was just
he was crying
he seemed so sorry but i knew i couldn't
just forgive him because
i
right that means it will happen again no
you know like i've seen the health class
videos
like everyone else and i got up in my
car i walked to the car
i didn't say anything i made a point
to not say oh it's okay or anything like
that i just didn't say anything
i got up i went to the car i sat in my
car
and i felt like i sat there forever i
didn't want to turn the key i just
leaned my head up against the window
and i remember
just seeing my breath on the
on the windshield you know on the the
glass of the of the window of the door
just
seeing my breath and trying
to will myself to
have the strength to
know what i should do in this moment
because
i was
heartbroken
and i sat there for a long time and
eventually
turned the key and drove home
what did you do after that
i don't know
i i don't remember what i did when i got
home i don't remember
um
i
went to my therapist
i told her
objection hearsay i
i'll sustain it as to what she made i
told her i went home and i
a few days later
i started getting
i actually don't know how many days
later but i started getting calls and
texts from johnny um
you know apologizing profusely i mean
just
you know he was
he said i'd rather cut my hand off than
ever
lay it on you or lay it upon you you
know and he had that way of talking it
felt like poetry
and uh he showed up
to talk like with the understanding that
you know he understood i could never
forgive him and it was done
so i felt kind of
safe and saying okay let's have a talk
or you know yeah we'll talk
i i i think you know i know i just
wanted to see him and he comes over
brings me gifts he brought me
a couple cases actually of that vega
cecilia wine that we've heard about
um which is a really nice expensive wine
that i could never at that time dream of
affording you know um
and we talk and
he
tells me that he had put this thing away
that i could trust him
that it would never happen again of
course it would never happen again
but he put this thing away he killed the
[ __ ] what he
said to me over and over again
i put that [ __ ] away i killed that
monster
i'll kill it again it's done
i'll never lay a hand on you again
and
i wanted to believe him so i chose to
stay in the relationship
yeah
i did i
i believed it
but you know i believe it wouldn't
i believe that there was a line he
wouldn't cross again and that was it
and
so you stayed
correct you stayed in the relationship
yes okay
so
just is this a good time you're going to
be keep going a little longer okay thank
you so could you please describe for the
jury
um
the evolution of your relationship after
that time with giant
um
i don't
i don't know how long it was until
things got bad again
uh
he did start drinking again
uh i remember
the
it was it was almost
you know he's start drinking again the
disappearing thing the coming back he'd
come back right like in the middle of
the night to my house
um
and he it would be unclear to me you
know drunk
often really drunk and
kind of accusing me but not directly it
was nothing was very direct it was a lot
of accusations but they were bailed um
you know what i was wearing who i was
with why didn't i text him back i didn't
text him back right away
um when i this is when i was at my place
in orange
sometimes he would show up to catch me
like that was a pretext for coming over
and by the time by the time we were done
talking
we'd be i would have thought i had
convinced him that i loved him that i
only loved him there was no one else and
then
that we were back in an upswing and
would go back to
good loving like sick romantic love
like kind
sweet velvety love
and then it would be
something i said why did you say it that
way
um
you know if i had to leave for an
audition
i could guarantee that when i not
couldn't guarantee but
two of those in a row and when i came
back he was angry at me you know and i
wouldn't necessarily know why and then
he started accusing me of things
probably like at first it was indirect
and then it became really direct then
the punching uh of the walls next to my
head which is a constant at the
at that time in 2012
when he was drinking um
eventually that became uh
you know him accusing me of cheating i'd
defend myself i'd say
you know that's crazy you're wrong i
would never the normal things
and uh
it would escalate to the point where
he'd push me or shove me down and then
i'd get back up and
this happened several times that's why
it's not more specific i suppose
when i get back up i
look him in the eye i made a point of
getting up
and looking him in the eye
it's my way of defending myself at that
time
and i'd look at him
and he'd ask me if i wanted to go again
and shove me back down eventually just
hit me
i remember he hit me in the face when i
denied having an affair with my ex-wife
my ex-partner at the time
and he said
he had proof i denied it
i was walking out of the bedroom slapped
me across the face i turned to look at
him
and i said johnny you hit me
you just hit me
[Music]
i'm gonna ask you michelle can you bring
up 1783 please
what number again please i'm sorry what
number defendants 1783 1783 thank you
do you recognize this
picture
yes i do and could you tell us what it
is
uh it's a picture of my face with um
a note that johnny left uh for me by the
coffee typically is where we'd leave
notes like that and does this accurately
depict the scene portrayed
it was one of those scenes i um
as embarrassing as it sounds now i don't
know which scene this came from there
was a lot it escalated quickly
fast and it was became
let me ask in a different way thank you
um
is this a picture of you
is it an accurate picture of you yes
you're right i'm going to move the
admission of 1783
your honor we have an objection
will you please describe for the jury
uh some of the cycles you had with mr
depp through 2012.
so
in 2012 the violence was
pretty
you know relative to what it became
pretty
you know slapping uh backhanding well it
went from
it went from this eggshell kind of
you're walking on eggshells nothing
you're doing is
kind of right but you don't know what
you're doing wrong
and then i was doing something wrong
clearly but they were it was unclear
within the scope of an argument what i
was defending myself against so it would
shift from
a rumor he had heard that i was with
my a friend or i had been photographed
standing too close to a male person
that was a person i'd have a and i had
had something with and i was lying to
him about and the
would be egg it would be eggshells
accusations accusations and then he
would explode
um it started with throwing things um
destroying the property and screaming at
me i remember
the screaming at me was
the worst because i kind of always felt
like i had done
you know i had to defend myself i had to
tell him so he didn't think these things
were true and sometimes
you know i he would shift accusations
while i'm trying to dispel one
accusation he'd start another one and
um
nothing i could do to calm him down
it seemed like you i'd walk away and
that would make it worse
i remember he
in my apartment in orange it would he
would grab me by the hair or he'd grab
me by the arm face pull me into him
scream at me that way he'd smash things
around me then he would smash things
very close to me
and then he would just hit me and it
started with
slapping
and it got to be like repetitive slaps
where he'd hold me
in a position and slap me multiple times
um in a row
then it would be
you know eventually i later would either
push him off of me or try to hit his
hands away from me and try to not in
2012 so much at that time i was mostly
my defense was
i'd go some other place like i don't
know how i don't know how to describe
that it was i focus on something else
i'd stand up
look at him
try to stand up to him that way later i
adopted other kind of
strategies to deal with it but
at the time in 2012 it was
he'd have this blowout and then he would
leave
disappear
and he would i'd be committed to not
talking to him i'm done with this
relationship i can't take it anymore
i said that so many times
and then he'd come back
clean and sober telling me either he had
a chip he didn't have any chips but he
would say i've i've gone to meetings
i have a i have a sober companion now
i'm doing this program i'm reading this
i'm doing this and he was done with
drugs and alcohol for good this time
and
he'd come back in my life and with the
combination of him being sober and
having gone through this horrible thing
where i felt like my heart ripped out of
my chest you know like a relationship
ending is hard i think for anyone but
ending under that circumstance is really
painful and so when he'd come back it
would almost feel like a solve
a solution to that and it would feel
great and we would be good again and it
would be
he'd be extra nice and extra apologetic
and extra loving and it would just
then we'd be back in in the good bubble
the warm glow
and
eventually it get bored and then i'd see
him
drinking again
when i started to get upset noticing the
pattern
of the violence going with the
drinking and drugs then i then he
started sneaking it so it became less
clear and i'd have to look for clues as
to what he was on so i just knew how to
react you know
uh johnny on speed is very different
from johnny and opiates and johnny and
opiates very different from
adderall and and
and cocaine johnny which is very
different from quaaludes johnny but i
had to get good at paying attention to
the different versions of him
uh 2012 i was in um
i was in the beginning stages of this
just learning these patterns i was just
learning that drinking kind of
correlated with the violence
and did you confide in anyone
about these issues you were having
i think she expected
i think she can say if she told anybody
as long as you say what she said
right right all right so did you con
did you tell anyone yes i did
who did you tell
i told my therapist
i
told i eventually told my mom
and let's uh let's go ahead and take a
look at
defendants exhibit 150
150 150.
your honor i'm going to object on
hearsay
i'm sorry
c
why
did you decide to
confide in your mother
about the issues you were having with mr
deb
i
i think i
i felt safe talking to
my mom because
i knew that she understood these
dynamics and
she wouldn't judge me
for staying with him
for loving him
even though
this was happening and was happening to
me
i knew she would understand
and when approximately did you start
confiding in your mom about your issues
with mr depp and physical
abuse
objection hearsay compound
i sustain is the compound
when did you start
confiding in your
mother
about the abuse you were
suffering at the hands of mr deb
i
well
i i was confiding in her from the very
beginning about the
abuse
the psychological abuse the kind of
control the disappearing the not knowing
where he was the then he'd come back and
sometimes in the middle of the night the
constant accusations like that sort of
thing i i talked to her about probably
from the very beginning
um the fact that i was secret i had to
hide
um
i couldn't tell any of my friends that i
was
with him for a long time because
he told me everyone would blame me for
the split with him and his partner so i
had to kind of sneak around and kind of
get
brought to his house typically
in a secretive way and then he'd come to
mind in a secretive way and it was just
all very you know so very isolating and
i
i confided with her
at the very beginning
on that sort of thing and then later
opened up to her about some of the
violence i did it gently
you know um
first i just wanted to have someone to
talk to about how scary it was you know
he'd
his the rage and the the uncontrolled
violence the rage that this man had and
why objection your honor hearsay may we
approach
ladies and gentlemen we're going to go
ahead and take our 15-minute afternoon
break so please do not talk about the
case we're doing the outside research
okay we'll see you soon
all right and mister just reminded that
now that you're on the stand you cannot
discuss your testimony with anybody to
include your attorneys okay
all right so we'll be back let's make it
355. okay thank you
all right we're ready for the jury yes
okay great
six
all right thank you please be seated
your next question
thank you your honor
amber i'm going to take you up to march
of 2013.
um can you describe your relationship
with mr depp
during that month
and
we'll start there
i remember
that was after a period of really
some it was after a period of some peace
and
then
um he and sobriety johnny was sober um
drinking becks
and my
dad
who was struggling with alcohol
and
drug addiction at the time had fallen
off the wagon and
and
i remember he said why don't we send it
i want to send a picture
to you to your dad of support
because
my sister was upset with my dad um
and so
he
poured a shot and um and and and kind of
said let's take a picture
uh i don't i don't drink spirits but i i
i know
that you know i kind of held up in that
picture it's kind of eerie because i
just think it's bizarre he had broken
this long period of sobriety that i
thought was
going to be the the end of him drinking
forever i
sounds foolish now but i you know held
up this kind of glass with him and we
sent the picture to my dad
because
you know i didn't know what else to do
and i remember thinking it was weird
that he was drinking and
um and then the month got
really crazy from that point on it was
um
a bit of
um
a revolving door of accusations uh he
was accusing me of having affairs with
um
well frankly just one person i hadn't i
was an acquaintance i had an
acquaintance with somebody and he was
accusing me of
of um of being with them and then it was
accusing me of being with my friend the
one i had seen in spain
uh i i'm you know in these kind of
arguments nothing i do is working i've
walking out of the room
it's me leaving him walking away from me
you know hey where are you going i'm
talking to you
that
it went from that to
um
pulling me in by by my arm
still shouting at the
about the accusations um
i'm trying to defu diffuse the situation
by trying to tell him i'm not sleeping
with this person and i'm not sleeping
with that person and it was kind of as
soon as it seemed as though i had
convinced him of one
there was somebody else he was sure i
was sleeping with um and
he it was a revolving door at that time
a painting i had hanging on the wall
done by my ex who's a artist
that was one day he
he was convinced that that was proof i
was sleeping with her or having an
affair with her
i didn't really love him and all the
while i'm madly in love with
him and trying to convince him so march
started with this picture of him
doing a shot and he's kind of saying
let's send it to your dad to show
support and
what i remember of march is just
like an almost no it's almost like it
was a never-ending fight it was just
there were breaks in it
what kept me in it is beca because i
kept waiting for the other
shoe to drop you know the sobriety
shoe if you will i kept waiting for
him to get
to the point where it's not supportable
or
anymore and he's done with it and he's
ready to get clean and sober again
because they're commences a period of
like pure joy
and
it was one
fight after the other march
so let me start with the painting
incident please tell the jury what
happened on that particular incident
with the painting
uh
as i mentioned
the painting which had been hanging
there
for
um months
uh
one day he he kind of stayed up doing
cocaine just
drinking doing cocaine music which is
not in and of itself that weird in my
relationship with johnny at this point
you know like he stays up and
keeps weird hours and he
smokes and stuff
but the the he was drinking um
brown liquor
and doing a lot of cocaine and it was
like
it became clear to me in that
argument if you will that it would he
wasn't making sense he had effectively
just
taken it seemed like a turn and had
decided that the painting
was
the big
an offense that he could not forgive me
for it meant i was having an affair with
my ex-partner
whom i had already split with whom i had
already split and it made no sense to me
so i'm trying to kind of quell the
accusations by saying
you know it's been there and what are
you talking about it's like that doesn't
mean anything and you know he was
demanding i take it down
he eventually takes it down and tries to
burn it but it was unsuccessful luckily
because he was not
he
didn't he wasn't
with
one of those normal what do you call
thick lighters he wasn't very successful
at doing it while drinking
um to the extent he was but i remember
it was this kind of
ridiculous fight like didn't feel like
it needed to be
an argument but it seemed like nothing i
could do
nothing i could say
i
tried leaving
i
left the room i left the house i
eventually came back it was
it was like a whole night
an evening a night and then a morning of
this
so this morning in particular i think it
was the like 22nd of march there were
several incidents in march though
um but in this particular one he had
something to go to he was filming with
keith richards and um
tom waits
let me before you go into that part
let's let's pull up uh
defendants exhibit 161
which is already admitted into evidence
i believe your honor
yes 161 with redactions thank you
and i'm going to
show you defendants exhibit 161
and the date on this is 312
2013 and it's a text exchange between
you
and mr depp do you see that i do okay
and the first one is from you to mr depp
i just thought you should know there
exists a book
is that to you is it to mr depp from you
or it's vice versa um it's johnny
texting me
just thought you should know there
exists a book titled disco bloodbath
and then you say we need that book
and you say is this about last friday
night by any chance and he says how can
you make me smile about such a hideous
moment
and i'm not going to repeat the rest of
it um could you tell the jury what
happened on that friday night
um
there were like i said there was a few
different
incidents in march um i believe this one
happened
in the eastern columbia building which
are one of johnny's penthouses they're
in downtown so a different part of los
angeles
and we'd sometimes
go there
i remember he was accusing me again of
um sleeping with this artist this
musician
who i'd never slept with
um
i was denying it i barely knew the
person uh and then he was accusing me of
of sleeping with my friend in spain
um
and i i remember nothing i could do he
like
called this person on the phone and
screamed at
screamed at him
um he didn't
speak english so he was really confused
as to what
he was being yelled at by johnny
um
but i remember those were the
accusations that that was the fight that
but it was one to the next accusation
and i remember i was kind of doing that
juggling act
i was in his one of these fights i
believe it's this one in his downtown
ecb we call it um
loft
and we're in the kitchen living room
area and he backhands me
and
you know
it was um
you know where's a lot of rings
uh i remember kind of just
feeling like that my lip went into my
teeth
and uh it got a little blood on the wall
just
that simple a little bit of blood on the
wall
as hard as it is
as hard as it is to explain this
i i was so caught up in the
relationship and also very occupied in
defending what i only as could assume he
believed these accusations
um that you know i didn't
i didn't
internalize like i didn't make that big
of a deal of it i'm you know i kind of
pride myself on being tough and
you know i don't make
a big deal out of
you know smaller injuries and i know
that
sounds
horrible because it
and hard maybe to understand but um
i mean my best way to cope with it is i
kind of
you know minimize it make me
make sure no one
make sure he knows that i'm
[Music]
i'm tough and
can't knock me down and
i make a joke of it clearly
make light
i'm going to uh michelle if you can take
this one down and
bring up 170a
did there come a time in march
amber where you sent a picture to your
mom uh yes this is um
sometime in march
uh 2013 i just i
i sent it to her because i've been
texting about some of the craziness and
i objection hearsay
i'll sustain as to what she may have
texted all right next question
without saying what you said in the text
explain why you were sending it to your
mom
i was
reaching out uh i was very lonely in
what i was living in and
i wanted help i wanted advice help
and some i just wanted to talk to
somebody
and
figure out how i can make this stop
and and is this a picture that you took
of yourself in march of 2013 i did
you're going to move the admission of
defendants exhibit 178
any objection no objection 170a in
evidence you can publish the picture
thank you
and how did you sustain that bruise
amber
um
i was
i had thrown a um
johnny slapped me i walked away from him
and that made it worse
we got into like a
shouting match
um
and he kind of did this thing with his
body where i could tell he was going to
hit me again
i picked up
like a
i remember it kind of like a um
like a little pop not a pot but um like
a base
and uh i i remember
i got away
from him enough as he reels back i threw
it in his direction
and got actually managed to get away
before he got it
before he got me
um he grabbed me by the arm
um
and he kind of just held me on the floor
screaming at me
i don't know how many times he hit me in
the face but
i remember being on the floor in my
apartment
and i'm just
i remember thinking
how could this happen to me again
can you bring up 170
thank you michelle and
if we can
and was just for
to start it's 3 23 2013 and if we can
scroll scroll up
this is a text message exchange with
your mom correct
yes it is okay let's go i mean scroll
down and then
your honor i'm going to object to
hearsay
let's wait until we get to the spot
all right and
is this the picture that you sent to
your mom on 323 2013
yes it is
your honor i'm going to move the
admission of 170 just that partic that
picture that's on the text
along with no words
well it says from two weeks ago
your honor i'll sustain the objection
if we redact the from two weeks ago can
we admit it then and then just have the
showing that she sent it to her
all right 170 will be in evidence with
redactions
and
may we publish to the jury please
and that's the picture you sent to your
mom
yes it is on march 23 2013.
yes it was from a previous fight okay
the breeze
all right now did you have any other
altercations in march 2013 with mr deb
yes um
we had um
we had a couple of these fights in
orange that were
[Music]
around this time one of which i started
to tell you about the painting you know
and i know i've interrupted you know
twice on that but i realize the jury
doesn't can you tell them what you mean
by orange at
orange sorry orange was my apartment
that i kept in los angeles at the time
and it was an apartment what type of an
apartment
i rented the top of a duplex so it was a
house and with the landlord living on
the bottom floor i
rented the top floor okay thank you now
please continue with the painting i'm
sorry
um
i nothing i could it seemed like nothing
i could say to johnny would convince him
he wanted me to remove the painting
and he wanted me to admit
to this affair that i wasn't having
and
i didn't want to admit to it because
it's not true
so i held out
and
he just started i mean he just drank
more and did more cocaine and i woke up
the next morning i think it was on the
22nd or the 23rd i woke up in the
morning and he was the breakfast table
was like
cocaine
and booze
and
i realized that
there
that
i wasn't going to be able to talk
my
like i wasn't going to be able to talk
our our our situation down i was going
to be able to talk him out of it and he
was just so convinced that i was
fighting with him or or or at the reason
that he wouldn't leave the house and he
had something to go film that was
important and there were important
people waiting for him and i remember
people were reaching out his
assistants his
manager sister
you know everyone was wondering where he
was and i
kind of i kept feeling
embarrassed and unable to move this
person
out of my house i couldn't calm him down
i couldn't change
he was just so intent on me admitting
the details of this affair that i i
wasn't having
and
me pointing out that the cocaine wasn't
making his situation any better made me
the bad cop
then i'm the nag
um so eventually i called my sister
he had a kind of a buddy-buddy
relationship with her at the time and at
the time she occasionally did cocaine
i didn't but she did so i was like hey
come take over
you know maybe you can buddy buddy him
and talk him into leaving the house just
getting out of the house
and she did um
i remember
his assistance trying to get him out
like we eventually in the evening i
think early evening he finally
agrees to leave but i can't tell our
relationship status i can't tell if he
still is convinced of these things or if
he's just going to sleep it off and
it's going to go back to
normal sobriety sorry kind of phase
and
uh he
was still upset but
like seemingly calming down so i
i agreed to go with him he wanted me to
go to the to the shoot
um
i had plans so i kind of reluctantly
agreed but didn't want to set anything
off i didn't want to engage anymore i
didn't want to do anything it could be
perceived as antagon antagonizing him or
engaging more so i went with him
we grab the dogs we get in the car we're
on the way there we're headed up
sweet sirs the street
it's a major street that
leads up to johnny's houses
he effectively owns the end of the
street it's like a cul-de-sac
so we're
nowhere near his home but we are driving
up this street and
he has a window down he's smoking um it
wasn't all the way down
but you know he's constantly smoking and
at some point he
starts howling
out of the window and then grabs
two small dogs well one was johnny's dog
and one was my dog but
he grabs
if i if i remember correctly boo the
the his his dog
um slightly
chunkier
teacup yorkie and he grabs this
teacup yorkie and holds
boo out of the window of the moving car
and
he's howling
like like an animal
while holding the dog out of the window
and
everyone in the car i'll never forget it
everyone just froze
no one did anything
and i i too was like
torn as to what i should do because i
didn't want to do anything to cause him
to react drop the dog you know it was
just this
eerie moment where he's
howling
and holding this animal outside of the
car window
and
more than that weird memory is the that
i have
more than that weird memory i have a
memory of everyone just kind of not
really reacting to him like no one
really kind of
did anything they
i eventually kind of pulled his arms
gently back into the to the
vehicle
and kind of got the dog back on the seat
and
we continued driving but no one
reacted
they just kind of avoided
dealing with it we get to the place the
house where he was filming this thing
that he was late for i suppose for the
day
and
we walk in
meanwhile i've been bombarded by text
messages and and calls and conversations
with everyone seemingly so stressed
about objection hearsay
all right
just
don't tell us what somebody else said
just what you observed i understood
everyone was stressed they seemed
stressed to me
about the tardiness
where is he let's get him there you know
so we get in there and no one reacts
when we get in i mean
we walk into this house where everyone
was waiting for him
and everyone smiles and says you know
hey bob objection you're saying okay
sorry let's uh can michelle can we pull
up
167
a
i think
is b b the one that's in 167 b is
already in right
oh it's a okay then go ahead and pull up
a
does your honor show that one to be in
167a
defendants i'm sorry well
this might be your 167a but it's an
evidence as a plaintiff's number and i'm
not sure which plaintiff's number it is
i don't need it in twice so i i would
agree
do we
your honor i don't think it's this
version of the photograph that's been
admitted so it's a different version
it's a different photograph but a little
different is that we're right it's not
the same photograph okay
and then we'll go with it what's your
what number is it
do you recognize this photo yes i do
please tell the jury what it is
it's a picture i took of my breakfast
table uh that morning
your honor i'm gonna move the admission
of defendants exhibit 167a
167a any objection
your honor may we approach sure
67a
is in evidence you can publish
so we may we publish that thank you your
honor
okay and
remember you said that you took this
that morning is that correct
could you tell the jury what the box is
that has the property with the skull
bones property of jd
um that's johnny's
drug box i've seen it used for pills but
at the time it was um bags of coke like
bags of coke okay and what are these
white lines on the table to the left of
that box
that is cooking okay
um
and do you know what is in these two
glasses that have kind of a gold colored
colored liquor
yes they're different actually it's
confusing they're different um
different liquids
the one in the back in the larger glass
is um
i i believe at the time i um was doing
these tabs or baroque that's what
they're called their little tablets and
um
anyway
i remember at the time
that that's what i was putting in my
water because i just come back from
france where they sell them and then the
brown liquid in the shot glass is um
johnny's liquor i don't know
what it's called but it we kept it in
the freezer
at the time it was
you know at that time march 2013 i
hadn't
you know um i still
didn't have the
you know
hard line i won't even keep that you
know in my freezer sort of attitude or
posture with him i wasn't that bold at
the time you know i didn't like it but
i didn't have that strength i kind of at
that time i think was
doing
things like trying to pour it out when i
could
so um what is the bag the brown bag on
the left side what is that
uh that's um
a dopp kit it's um
like
you know his prescriptions and um
cigarette tobacco weed things that like
that
okay and then above it there appears to
be a cd of some sort uh dvd something
do you recognize that yes it's um the
single i
i believe it's what it's called the
single he was making at the time and i
think that's the song that they were
filming a video for if i'm correct
okay
all right now did you end up sending a
copy of this picture to rocky pennington
that day
i did i
sent it to my best friend at the time
and
you know i was like look at my morning
objection hearsay okay you can't say
what you said but you sent it to your
friend correct let's go to 167 please
and is that the email in which you sent
this picture to rocky pennington on 322
yes 2013. yeah i'd like to move the
admission of
the picture with the redaction of the
message on it
uh with the
top
with identifier redactions and we take
out the rest of it
all right any objection no objection all
right so i'm going to do those
redactions 167 and evidence with
redactions
all right
and may we publish please
all right and is this the
text message the email that you sent to
rocky with this picture
yes okay
now i'm going to
take you to
let's go to
hicksville
let's tell the jury about hicksville may
2013.
can you tell the jury what transpired at
hicksville
uh it is a
it's a
like a fancy
um trailer park
like a little hotel in the middle of
nowhere
um set up with these little trailers and
uh we had made um
a plan to go there with friends and um
we were gonna do
you know like laffy as we said laffy
drugs like
mushrooms eat mushrooms sit by a
campfire
um
there's really not a whole lot else to
do out there it's like a getaway
um we had made this plan
and it was going fine it was like a you
know kind of like a party out in the
desert
with a few friends and
campfire and music and um
i i don't know who brought somebody
brought mdma
was being passed around and somebody who
who took it
um
kind of was starting to feel the effects
of it i guess is the best way to
describe she kind of reacted in this way
where
when the mdma hit her she kind of
you know we were sitting around and
can't fire all of us and she kind of
just leaned into me
and put her
you know head on my shoulder
and kind of grab my arm i took it you
know to be the effects of the drug
um
and
uh
i think i had eaten a mushroom cap
but
was
not feeling anything at the time
um i don't remember feeling anything um
because the night just kind of changed
pretty dramatically
before i really felt anything of the
effects of that but
that was the
environment we were in and
and
as soon as she kind of did this thing
where she leaned into me
johnny
gets really
activated he gets really upset and he
starts well at first she thought he was
kidding too she thought he was kind of
making a joke i think we all did
everyone kind of responded at first you
know that like it was a joke but he
was like um hey man what are you doing
you know what what do you what do you
think you're doing and she kind of
giggled and kind of leaned into me more
and i knew in my body just
instantly
that it wasn't a joke
but she didn't so she's kind of still
attached to my arm when he says it again
to her louder
he says hey man you think you're
touching my [ __ ] girl
you think you're touching my [ __ ]
girl that's my [ __ ] girl
and he gets louder and louder
and she kind of
did this thing half
understanding what was going on i think
she kind of started to cry at this point
but she kind of threw up her hands and
johnny grabbed her her wrist
and kind of twisted it
and
pulled her into him and said do you know
how many pounds of pressure it takes to
break a human wrist
huh
and he kind of held her and she just she
just looked
frozen
and
she's crying and
she's it was just
denying
understanding what was going on i
stepped in
i
kind of
take johnny's arm around trying to take
johnny's hand and kind of
we start
communicating i don't remember if he
immediately was accusing me or if it was
some time after i wish i remembered but
we
we agreed that we'd go and talk about it
in the trailer
so we walked to the trailer um
and when we're in the trailer
johnny by the time we get into the
trailer johnny tells me that
i
had been
instigating the
uh like you know and
asking for this
and that i had invited it and that i i
hadn't been honest with him about my
relationship with this woman and not to
i didn't really know her that well i
mean i actually don't know her at all
but
i had met her and
i remember in the trailer um he's
accusing me of of lying about it
and that i you know that i had something
with her i'm trying to defuse that i'm
trying to calm him down and
um he just turned all that um it seemed
like he turned all that rage onto the
trailer itself
and he started smashing things
he picked up something on the table and
threw it right into the glass cabinet
he hit with his hand
a wall sconce
he cleared the table top on the little
fold down
um
like kitchen
dining room area in this trailer i mean
it's a trailer so there's only so much
you can do
and he's screaming at me he's just
screaming at me
um and i i uh eventually go back into
the back
the bedroom area
uh
he comes into the bedroom area we
had what i can only describe as
a uh
it sounded like nonsense from him it
wasn't making sense and i realized that
he's just probably really high
because it wasn't making sense anymore
it wasn't like a direct accusation i
wasn't he wasn't hearing me when i was
saying i i
i
wasn't involved wasn't cheating on him i
wasn't secretly trying to engage this
woman
and some sort of sexual affair um and
and then it became clear to me he was
like looking for something he
um
cleared things off the bed
i went into the bathroom
and as i come out
um he's at he asked me where it is
and how long i've been hiding it
i was like what are you talking about
and he says you know what i'm [ __ ]
talking about you know what i'm [ __ ]
talking about be honest with me
where are you hiding it and he kind of
like makes to look into the bathroom
um and i gestured to the bathroom which
was to my right i kind of like gestured
to him and i said
like
what am i where am i good at what am i
hiding and where am i going to hide it
and and we're standing in this little
hallway area
outside of the bathroom and
he starts
you know
what it feels like patting me down or
saying he's patting me down i can't
recall but
he ripped my dress
the
strap top part of my dress
i had just dyed this thing um myself
pink and i
it's just one of those things i
was like
you know that's my
just finished that dress
and um he's like grabbing my
my breasts he's touching my thighs
and he rips my underwear off
and then
he
proceeds to do a cavity search
he was looking he said he was looking
for his drugs his cocaine his coke
i was wondering how i somebody who
didn't do cocaine
and was against it
that was in and of itself causing
problems in our relationship
how could i hide why would i hide
his drugs from like like he was
insinuating that i was doing it or
something it made no sense
and
he was telling me we're doing we're
gonna we're gonna conduct a cavity
search shall we
like
just shoved his fingers inside me
just stood there staring at the stupid
light
you know what you know i didn't know
what to do i just did it
i just stood there
while he did that he twisted his fingers
around
i don't
i didn't see like
stop or anything i just
so the next morning
um
what what transpired
i remember thinking that
johnny would
change his mind
um
and it would be
um
yeah i thought it would
end differently i kind of froze i don't
know how
we went to bed that night i don't know
how i went to bed i don't know how i
slept i don't know how he woke up i
don't remember
having a conversation with him the next
day i don't remember
talking to him about it or confronting
him about it i'm i'm i remember wanting
it to be okay i remember just wanting
whatever [ __ ] weird trip excuse me
whatever
trip that was to end
you know just to be over and for it to
just
go back to normal
um i remember my friends were out by the
pool
like the there was a pool in the center
of the trailer park and i remember
putting on my
you know just putting on my
face
and going back into this like crap you
know and i remember seeing my friends by
the pool thinking they were just having
a great time and no one knew what was
you know i felt so lonely like no one
knows what's
everyone's just having a good time you
know like normal stuff so i just smiled
made a joke about how trashed the
trailer got and
we had to get the manager
uh who started off furious
that johnny had wrecked the thing
and then
he had this like black mesh tank top and
not tank top that was like a meshy kind
of shirt on and i remember he came into
the trailer and looked around and was
like
whoa what happened here whoa
and johnny
had an exchange with him
and i remember watching this man be so
charmed
it was kind of a surreal experience and
you know it just went away you know that
just
got fixed we walked out of the trailer
at some point
my dog stepped on a bee
we went to the bet
and went on with our
you know vacation we actually went to
another location after that and then
eventually went home and
went about our
like
i'm going to ask you to take a look
michelle can you bring up defendants and
see what 176.
did there come a time that you
wrote an email objection leading and
hearsay your honor may we approach
in june
2013
how were you feeling about your
relationship with mr depp
may we have the exhibit taken away from
thank you
i
um
by
june i was
so torn
i was so in love with this person
because when it was good it was so good
you've never felt love like that at
least that's how it felt
so much
i felt like he recognized me and i
recognized him and there was just
something
there that
that is the love of my life
and he was
he was but he was also this other thing
it was also this other thing
and that other thing was
awful
awful thing that would
come out and
take over and it was
you couldn't see the johnny i loved
underneath it it was this other
thing
and no one told him no one was honest
with him no one
you know he'd pass out
in his own vomit he'd lose control of
his
body his
you know he'd lose control and everyone
clean up after him i cleaned up after
him
i mean this man lost control of his
bowels and i cleaned up after him
isn't his security cleaned up after him
changed his pants in front of me he
would pass out his own sick
you know and then he'd walk around
saying
he didn't have a problem
until he did
until he couldn't support it anymore and
it'd get clean and he'd get sober and
then he was this thing again
this thing that made me feel so loved
that made me feel like
like my
like my soul mate as cheesy as that
sound i just felt like he knew me
and i recognized something in him either
some part of my makeup and my background
or something that i just got it and i
loved him and understood him it just got
so
scary the other part of him
and
in june i wanted
wanted to leave him
i wanted to
i didn't want to leave him i
wanted to want to leave him i wanted him
to get better
and he expressed to me so many times
when he was in that
period of getting clean and sober he
would tell me you saved my life
baby girl you saved my life
everyone else was saying that to me and
i believed it
you know if everyone else was saying it
he was saying it i thought
just like his other friends who had
gotten clean and sober and stayed that
way his older friends these rock stars
that he hung out with that had like
gotten clean and sober and they had 20
30 years something you know i thought
and johnny told me he
would be that person that he was gonna
be that person and i believed it
i had so much i looked at that man
twice my age
you know i was
25
looking at this man twice my age and i
saw hope
and like promise i had so much hope
you know the whole thing
kids and growing old together sort of
hope
if it was just for this one thing that
he could do
which would save his life which would be
to get clean and sober
and i believed it
and i wrote this letter to myself among
many letters to myself objection
all she did was refer to that she wrote
it she isn't saying what she said oh
rule for that thank you okay
i wrote that letter because i
thought
it would be read to him
i could read it to him i could say it to
him in intervention you know in help and
he would
he would later
thank me
for
as he did as he used to thank me all the
time for saving his life just i
did there come a time later in june
that you finally met johnny's kids
i'm sorry um
yeah i um
i finally met them in the summer of
2013.
i had been with
johnny for over a year
maybe like a year and a half at this
point
is my best guess
and i was dying to meet them you know
dying
to get to know these kids i felt like i
knew them already
i had
his daughters uh and actually and jax
both both his kids aren't on my fridge
and i had never even met them you know
johnny brought them over one day and
kindly
given them to me and i had them up on my
fridge because i felt like i knew them
just how much you talked about them and
i finally got to meet them
at the lone ranger premiere
at disneyland
uh yeah summer 2013.
[Music]
so then i'm gonna
jump to and it's not much of a jump to
june 26 2013
there was a plane ride to russia with
johnny do you recall that yes
tell the jury about that particular
event
uh well that was the
first and last time i ever
decided it would be a
a decent idea to do drugs with johnny
um i did mdma with or
did mdma with him on the plane
which was as stupid as it may sound
i just had never
i was very against obviously the cocaine
had been
a problem i was very much against him
using cocaine
i was against the drinking
supportive of the sobriety
you know but
i'm 26
maybe uh
ish
and i i wanted you know i had never
heard of anyone making mdma
like what i had
i had done mma before you know i thought
it's a lovely drug it's a you know
it's like
a kind of i never knew anyone to
get violent on it
and um
you know
i thought well this is relatively
contained environment
maybe this will be different maybe i can
be good cop and be part of the you know
like i don't have to be
the lesbian counselor all the time as
you would say you know i could maybe be
the fun girlfriend
and i learned the hard way that that was
not happening
so what happened
well
we took um we took mdma i took a capsule
um it's like a powder
in a capsule
i took a capsule and
johnny took
several i didn't count but um
you know it's very different when you
see someone take one versus a handful of
something but
nothing seemed
to set any alarm bells off and it things
were going fine until
until the flight attendant got involved
the flight attendant came by
was engaging with us uh
i i don't think that there really
it felt like it was before the effects
of the drug um
took over it was so it was relatively
quick soon after we first took
our dose
if you can say and
the flight attendant um
johnny offered her some she of course
said no and then after some back and
forth between them johnny convinced her
that it would be fine so she
acquiesced and took
uh mdma with us it's
and within
you know a few minutes go by and
cl that the same thing
happened um
that happened on the mushrooms at
hicksville uh with
the woman kelly sue who i've told you
about uh flight attendant got friendly
with me but just friendly just like
mdma friendly you know was kind of i'm a
woman he's a man so she was naturally i
think more comfortable with me
physically she kind of leaned into me
and kind of sat on the arm of the chair
i was sitting in
i mean after all she
she's on drugs and
um
johnny
grabs grabs her hand
and tells her not to touch me and she
kind of reacts
in a way
like you know like defending herself and
was trying to clear clarify
and
grabbed her by the wrist
and
slammed it down on the table
and told her he could break her wrist
and i remember thinking i've heard this
before
and
that was a pattern that would repeat
itself a few times
these things would happen in these kind
of cycles where there would be a certain
element that would get filtered for a
while whether it's an accusation or a
gesture and that would be the thing that
he looped on i called it looped
loops
and he grabs her wrist and he tells her
he can break her wrist
she
cries instantly denies it is
so apologetic
go eventually he lets go she goes to the
front of the plane where the flight
attendant you know normally hangs out
and the doors close and i don't see her
much of that whole flight
we land in russia
and i don't really remember
you know any there was i don't recall
any violence on the plane
um between johnny and i but i remember
feeling this tension because i was
wondering when
uh it was gonna
aim at me
because he had this particular thing
about well at the time i understood he
had a particular thing a sensitivity
about me and women because i had had a
female partner
so i
was feeling nervous
anxious and i remember
we had a very quiet
ride at least i didn't say anything um
to the right to the hotel
and almost as soon as we get into the
hotel room
um
johnny's accusing me of
effectively
having um
engaged that uh
caused that
um i of course deny it uh point out what
i thought was obvious
that you know like we we'd given her
drugs you know it's
wasn't an affair wasn't you know and i'm
trying to argue and defend myself at the
same time and
um
at one point johnny just shoves me like
i mean just
shoves
it
shoves me
hard i fall back onto this glass table
i catch myself on the table
i don't know how
some furniture got knocked around there
was a you know i i'm trying to stand up
for myself i'm trying to stand up
literally i'm not you know at this point
i don't even try to hit back or try to
run
i'm in this hotel room trying to do my
best to fight mostly the verbal
accusations but also i try to stay on my
feet you know
um
at some point uh
johnny whacks me in the face
and
i don't even
i don't remember feeling
pain or like awareness of my nose or
anything i just
i don't remember thinking that i
remember kind of
crying and
feeling i went into the bathroom and i i
wanted him to
have a like i i just remember wanting
him to realize what had happened i
wanted him to kind of snap out of it i
wanted him
to care i wanted him to realize what was
going on because a big part of this i
felt like he wasn't aware there was a
sense that he didn't know what was going
on
you know
again i don't know how much of the drugs
or alcohol is a part of this but
i remember crying i came out at some
point because
i don't hear him in that room i remember
we had been arguing in the main room but
i went out to the hallway which is where
i presume he walked out
and his bodyguard jerry judge was in the
hall
and i don't recall seeing johnny in the
hallway but i remember seeing jerry
judge who
um gestured to
hearsay
she's just saying gesture he hasn't said
anything yet all right gesture's fine
i'll overrule the objection
he gestures to my nose
um
and
holds out his
handkerchief like a cloth handkerchief
and i
instantly felt
i just felt really embarrassed
i felt like i felt ashamed i don't know
how to describe it i just felt like
just really embarrassing and i went
inside the room
what if any injury did you have
i had a little blood coming out of my
nose
i didn't know it i didn't feel it at the
time until jerry gave me the
jerry let me know
okay
and i went inside the um
the hotel room and
uh it
is embarrassing as it is i
i i i remember uh just wanting
i remember just wanting johnny to
say sorry i wanted him to realize it
it's so stupid but i
like the emotional part you know i just
wanted him to acknowledge that
this was um
that he like he could hurt me you know
and
i wanted it to be okay i didn't want him
to think i was interested in this flight
attendant i didn't want him to think
that i would capable of cheating on him
i was in love with him
i wanted you know i just wanted things
to be okay
let's take you to july 9 2013.
did there come a time that you went for
a ride on you went to the bahamas and
went on a ride
the yacht with johnny and his kids
well it's less like a
we flew out to the bahamas to his island
he was selling the yacht to jk rowling
and he wanted to kind of have a goodbye
trip on the yacht so it was docked off
the island and i went with him
and his
kids who i
had quickly developed a bond with and
loved and
we brought a friend along with us i
think to kind of
help
and
yeah
okay
tell tell the jury what happened on that
trip
johnny was uh upset that he had to sell
the boat
uh and he was
off the wagon again
but he didn't want to tell his kids so
he was hiding it from them
he was putting it in
coffee cups
and drinking and the behavior just kind
of like he was upset he was emotional
and it just
you know that's how he dealt with it
just drink
but there's just no off button with
johnny so he just kept drinking and the
behavior kept getting more obviously
drunk and lily rose his daughter at the
time was young
she's like maybe 14
and she started to
get panicky
and asked started to ask me questions
about his drinking objection hearsay
without saying what lily rose was saying
please continue on
sustain the objection thank you so she
was asking me questions about the
drinking
um and was very upset in the objection
yeah you can't say what lily rose said
but you can you can tell gestures you
can tell and you can say what you and mr
depp said okay
sorry um
so
she was upset and uh
johnny kind of
we were with the kids and he kind of
threw himself off the boat in a
half playful way
um like a dead
like dead fish kind of way i don't know
how to describe it almost like a belly
flop but
we were on a skip like a smaller boat
parked next to the yacht and he's
jumping
well he jumped off the front of it but
kind of in a
face
chest forward way like
it looked a little scary like not
something somebody would do if they're
completely okay you know it was
it was
started off all of us kind of taking
turns jumping off the edge of the yacht
uh
into the water and then he
at one point
kind of throws himself over and it
looked a little scary
the way his body fell into the water and
lily rose
started to cry
and
expressed to me that she objection here
is a sustained you you can't say what
she said you can say you can
tell expressions or observations but you
can't say what lily rose said so lily
rose is crying
and then the crying becomes like um
like a panic
like like almost like a panic attack uh
it like rapid breathing
crying
lots of questions
and i'm holding her and kind of
comforting her and johnny comes in
and within a few
[Music]
within a few seconds i realized that he
you know kind of shifted his attention
on me and then he
seemed very angry
uh
he asked lily rose to leave
lily rose
leaves
looks at me leaves crying and johnny
in
i don't remember the word to use but
starts accusing me of kind of
like telling on him
and
calling him
um uh you know a drunk in front of his
kids i hadn't i hadn't done that
i was actually trying to protect johnny
uh
i wasn't it didn't feel like my place at
all to share that with with his daughter
or anyone um at the time other than
adults who might help with it but not
his kids
so
i was trying to tell him i'm
i was just trying to comfort her i was
trying to protect you
he uh
basically was accusing me of doing this
thing and
of of making them aware of his
uh that he was drinking again
and he slams me up against the the side
wall of the bedroom of the cat we were
in the bedroom this whole time but up
against the wall of the cabin
and slams me up by my neck
and holds me there for a second and
tells me that he
he could [ __ ] kill me
and that was an embarrassment
i was embarrassing it was embarrassment
this whole thing was a joke
all embarrassment i made him feel sick
and
i'll never forget
i'm i'm i'm
i was
i'm very very
very much in love with this whole family
now and he's saying i'm embarrassing to
him
and that somehow stuck in in in me more
than the i could [ __ ] kill you it
just sounded like hyperbole it sounded
like something he was just
saying but
the names that he was calling me
kind of just pushing me up against the
wall by my neck you know i
hurt it hurt my feelings it hurt
um i
uh when i communicated with when i saw
lily rose again we get
uh
i won't say what she told me but the
next thing we do is we call for a
helicopter to come and take us off of
the
um boat or off of the island so we leave
the boat go to the
landing
um of a a a part of the island or maybe
it was a different you know island we
had to get to to leave when we
we take off i'm holding lily rose in my
i'm
literally holding her under my arm while
she's crying and we're lifting off and
jack ended up not coming with us at the
last minute he stayed behind um
and we were taking off and i
remember being really torn about leaving
i
i i felt bad about leaving even though
that
that that had happened i still felt
awful leaving i felt awful leaving him i
i i also felt like
i had done something wrong you know
like he was mad at me i wasn't
sure you know
or what i had done but i i remember not
being you know i'm i'm getting all these
text messages from him calling me all
these names and
it was barely coherent barely and i'm
holding his daughter crying
and let me just stop you for a moment
michelle can you pick pull up defendants
exhibit 180
do you believe that's already it is
already into evidence your honor so if
we may publish it to the jury
and amber i'm going to ask you to take a
look at 180
and
this is text messages from mr depp to
you
do you recall these
yes i do and and are these the text
messages yes that's what he was sending
me while i was
taking care of his daughter
so
your honor i'm about to go into another
event should i keep going
i mean that's fine if you think this is
a good point to break for the day i
think it's probably good all right
ladies and gentlemen we'll go ahead and
conclude for today again do not read
anything about this case do not do any
outside research and don't discuss it
with anybody okay have a good evening
we'll see in the morning okay
thank you
and again ma'am since you're still in
the stand you cannot discuss your
testimony with anybody to include your
attorneys okay
all right anything further before all
right we'll see you in the morning thank
you
you